hey everyone welcome we're going to
start up
now welcome to this next live session
of whatever you want to call it your
daily equation
was the original name many of you are
familiar with that series that we
started during the pandemic
or world science u or a hybrid of the
two whatever you want to call it of
course we're meeting today
at a different day and a different time
than we are used to partly that's
because
look i mean the world is is carrying
forward
and the usual constraints of the
academic life are coming to bear
on my schedule and the schedule of all
those that we
would like to talk to during these
sessions as well you may recall we were
typically doing these fridays at 3 p.m
but i now
teach fridays from 2 to 5 p.m so that
slot
has gone away for that reason so we'll
experiment a little bounce the time and
day around
and hopefully you just sort of keep
aware of the schedule through either the
world science
festival website or the youtube page you
should subscribe if you're not already a
subscriber so you can
be up to date on the sessions that we
are going to have
and today is a a particularly fun
session you may recall there was
some spectacular news
back in 2015 that
shook the world of physics both
metaphorically and as we will discuss
literally when the first detection of
gravitational waves was
achieved by the ligo collaboration and
you will remember we'll talk about this
in just a minute
gravitational waves is an implication
of einstein's general theory of
relativity
it was an implication that einstein
himself
kind of struggled with in trying to
determine whether it was a bonafide
prediction or whether it was something
that ever would be detected
i'd say the majority of physicists
before the detection
probably thought it was unlikely that we
would achieve a detection within our
lifetime
but there were some scientists who were
braver
than all of us some scientists willing
to put
everything on the line for what
could be one of the great discoveries
of our age and those are the scientists
who are the real heroes of the story
that we'll be talking about
here today and i'm thrilled that
one of those heroes one of those
great scientists from the ligo
collaboration
is joining us today who is going to take
us through
this wonderful dramatic story
of scientific achievement so with that
i'm pleased to bring in
gabriella gonzalez from the ligo
collaboration and gabby
is a is chief spokesperson for the ligo
collaboration if i have that
correctly and she and i have spoken
in various contexts about the discovery
of gravitational waves
throughout the last couple of years but
i'd like to start with gaby if you don't
mind before we get into the cutting edge
research
and and all that sort of stuff let me
just quickly ask where are you joining
us
from at the moment hi well it's very
nice to be here even if virtually i
would like to be
visiting beautiful new york city i am in
baton rouge louisiana that's where i
live i
teach also monday wednesday friday at
louisiana state university and and how
has the um
how is the pandemic i mean it's affected
us all in in a
in a wide variety of ways but
are you guys able to get back to work uh
how's teaching
happen for instance well teaching is a
completely new experience because it's
the first time and
i'm going to be teach i am teaching
online uh
i'm teaching a large introductory class
and that is done online
for the for safety uh and i
like to teach in an interactive way
and and that of course it takes
it takes a lot of learning let's say
that my students are learning
and i am learning a lot too and what's
the subject
in the introductory class introductory
physics or is it is it gravity or
yeah it's electricity and magnetism
which of course has a lot to do with
interferometers and the detectors we use
you know electricity and magnetism the
introductory course to my mind
is the first real step toward
abstraction that
that many students take i mean when
you're talking about mechanics and you
can
think about balls flying through the air
you can picture it you can do it but all
of a sudden
this weird thing called the
electromagnetic field that you can't see
or feel or touch in any direct way the
way you can
touch tables and objects it's it's a
leap forward yeah
yes it's a lot more abstract i mean we
can see masses moving we can imagine
planets we've been
learning about planets from from school
but to think about electric charges i
mean
apart from from electrostatics and
things that
make my hair frizzy that there is a lot
of experience with electricity
that's about it that's right it's so
easy to take for granted
that these concepts are somehow second
nature when you deal with them
every day as a professional but man when
you first encounter
the idea of electric charge and and
electric fields uh it's hard it's very
hard
yeah so what's your own speaking of uh
the beginning stages
of becoming a physicist what's your own
story where where were you born and and
uh
were you like a physics uh were you
building like the proverbial
radiology chemistry set that kind of a
thing or is it a different one
i was not i was not actually i'm
i was born in argentina you can tell i
wasn't born in the us from my accent i
was
born in a big city cordoba in argentina
and i was very curious my mom says that
and i remember that i i was
i would ask about everything and i also
liked math in school
so in high school my parents because i
liked all of this they looked for a
school that had a that was specialized
in chemistry
so i have an associate chemistry degree
or something like that from from high
school
and in learning chemistry and physics we
took these classes from early on and 13
14 years old
uh i love the explanations i love
being able to explain everything and i
thought
physics was the science that could
explain everything because
it explained atoms some chemistries
about atoms it explained motion of
planets
so physics was everything yeah
so were you either kind of were you
going around and uh
pointing out to people hey you know you
see that that that spinning wheel over
there
let me give you the formula for the the
velocity in terms of the angular motion
and things of that yeah i was a tutor
and i worked as a teacher
my classmates for free but also for many
yeah but but presumably at some point
you came to the realization that the
explanations that physics could give
could explain some things but there was
still room
they were still get in on it and to me
that was a surprise
because i went to college in fact it
must be very different now because of
these programs because of youtube and
documentaries but in that
in that time i mean i i started college
in 83 that's
that's a long while ago but in argentina
when
the internet didn't exist it was
beginning to exist
anyway i went to college to learn
explanations that i thought were already
in the books i just wanted to learn i
didn't think about
practicing science or practicing physics
i just wanted to
learn yeah and there i realized that of
course we took classes and in classes
every
everything we learned in classes were
things that were hundreds of years old
but the teachers the professors were
scientists were people who were
investigating things that
questions that didn't have answers and
posting new questions
it wasn't not only that answers didn't
exist
to every question not all the questions
had been asked yet and i
loved that and that's when i wanted to
become a scientist myself too so did you
start in
did you do research as an undergraduate
or indeed
in argentina the college degree is a lot
more specialized than here in the us so
it's a five-year degree
in which we only take physics and math
classes really
and i ended and it ends with a thesis
uh i had a paper a couple of papers
published with my
with my undergrad and my college thesis
and it wasn't the theory eisen theory of
relativity that's
that's the area i wanted to do
researching
and you and you did research in in
relativity yes
yes at that young age were you were
able to actually get into some real
physics problems i guess if you're only
studying physics maybe you got advanced
enough quickly
yes yes actually we we did um
the we had to have a thesis
that was associated with a research
group so i chose this group that was
very active
on ice and theory relativity it was
actually looking for
exact solutions to isis equations there
are quite actually quite a few no
not as many as relevant as as the
numerical ones that we have but that's
what i was doing
i also like to say that in doing that
research i provided wrong
at that age what do you mean by that
because um actually
i met my husband doing this research my
husband
uh was studying his uh was doing his phd
in a different
university in the south of argentina but
he uh he actually wanted to do his
phd thesis also on the theory of
relativity but that was not the research
group
where he was studying so he came to
cordova to the university i was at to do
his research
for his phd and that's how we met thanks
to
einstein and isis said that he couldn't
be blamed his theory couldn't be blank
for people falling in love
and we took it wrong
i see that's very good that is very good
he's had a lot of other things too my
goodness we start to go down that
direction
that is great so so you you were looking
at exact solutions
of the einstein field equations that
applied to cosmology
presumably yes
i'm sorry go ahead my thesis was called
solitonic cosmologies
i see and and so were you thinking that
you would be a theorist
is yes even at an early age that that
was where
i see and then and then so from from
argentina
you you came to the united states at
some point
uh when was that and where did you go
but just right after finishing
uh college my husband uh finished his
ph.d
and we came to the us to syria at this
university he came with a postdoctoral
fellowship
i came to start my ph.d studies and it
was in syracuse university
actually started my phd thesis on on
on theory on theoretical research of
relativity
looking for defining using new variables
to define some conserved quantities
sure and very mathematical relativity
but then
a professor joined syracuse university
that was working with the project
that was very mysterious called ligo
that was going to measure space-time and
space time so
yeah so that that caught your attention
no doubt
oh yeah well i actually had to you know
in
in phd studies you have to take in most
in most universities you
have to take a graduate lab course right
and in in syracuse we had to
choose a research group to do a semester
long project
so i i chose his group because he was
just a new professor doing some the
experimental gravity i mean and i was
doing gravity so it was a natural
love to do he was just setting up the
lab so i was helping him set up the
optical tables and setting up this
this is peter's also at syracuse
university just retired
this year and and i loved
the idea of i had i had done very very
few experiments before
and experiments in which you knew the
results so
here not only uh learning that
but you i was able to do things with my
hands with
measuring data but the answer was not
known
uh and and that that was part that was a
building brick of something that it was
going to be so big
and it was it was amazing and i just
fell in love
again but this time with ligo yeah now
it's so interesting because
i had in mind when i was an
undergraduate that the only thing that i
ever wanted to do was
manipulate mathematical equations so i
engineered it and it was possible to do
this
in those days to never take a laboratory
to never touch and it was the biggest
mistake
of my of my education to do that
because as you're saying you know if
you're in the world of abstract
ideas and you never sort of reach out
and get your fingers
dirty there's a there's a separation
disconnect exactly right way of saying
it so much so that i have to tell you
when i
went to the san francisco exploratorium
this is many years ago
right and and i walked in because i was
given some talk or something like that
had like a few
20 minutes of walking around and there's
this cloud chamber
and i'd never actually looked at one
i've read about them i knew about them
i'd never
and when i saw the particles
streaming through this these are real
particles coming
i was mesmerized that was like it's
renal
the particles that we talk about in
quantum field theory course
they're actually out there and and to
never have that
experience in a deeper way we're
actually doing the experiment
is a big loss so all of you folks out
there listening who
are enamored with the mathematics
enamored with the theory
listen to gabby's experience not to my
experience or at least learn from my
mistake
you've got to be willing to get out
there and do
the real work that allows you to connect
the abstract to the
the experimental so anyway so you did
that
you did that that that project there and
and they were basically swept away
i guess by the possibility of of pushing
the frontier of understanding
through the potential detection of
gravitational waves
so what what year was that though was
that late i finished my phd in 95
95. yeah and and and and now i recall
you know feeling the general consensus
of the world of physics
in the mid 90s and again tell me if you
felt it differently but there's a
general sense of there are these people
who are out there trying to measure
gravitational waves
and man are they misguided what
what are they doing because it's just
so unlikely that they will ever realize
that goal was was that a sense that was
palpable
for the researcher i'm i'm not so sure
no i don't i wouldn't think so because
like i said syracuse university had just
hired this professor so
so they wanted this and and the people
in the in the group i was the group was
led by abayastica
uh that time in syracuse he was actually
very
supportive
he was part of this effort to hire the
person
in what was a very very new field i
think at that time
the groups doing experimental gravity
i mean related to gravitational waves
where can tech mit
with ligo colorado
well of course the university of
maryland with weber
and but lsu lsu was doing
had a bar also
whoever is a good example right so some
people
i mean maybe you can tell us a little
bit about him in the experiment because
that is sort of the the initial black
eye if you will
of gravitational wave detection i i
don't know if that's a description yes
but you know uh
even before meeting peter saltzon this
was in my first year
at syracuse university before peters
also joined i went to a small
it was a small meeting in pittsburgh
another famous mathematical physicist in
relativity that new man it was his
birthday so
we were uh celebrating that birthday and
that meant it was a small meeting but it
was amazing because
it was it was the first time i really
felt
alone as a woman i mean there was one
other woman there
beverly berger who is also very
important in the field
uh but we were the only two women there
so that was already
strange but in the meeting um joe weber
was there and keith thorne was there
and joe webber was presenting a new
result he had been
claiming he had claimed that he had seen
gravitational waves in the 70s and
of course other people had tried to
reproduce that and they couldn't so it
was not believed
but then in 1987 there had been this
supernova
and he claimed that he had seen
gravitational waves in his bars and
italian bars in coincidence um
and people didn't believe it because
well there were few other bars in
actually there were almost no other
birds there were other bars in
around the world much more sensitive
than his but
they were not working because they were
starting to coordinate
iran in the future so anyway his bars
were the only one working
and he said that he had seen this but it
was
i mean calculations proved that it was
impossible and he said that it was
because his bars were more sensitive
because of the way
the atoms interrupted in the bar and
there was a discussion
and a very uh
a very respectful but intense discussion
between weber and and
keeps on job evan and keeps on this and
i said wow this was
when i was still a theory is that yeah i
was presenting there
work on on something i was working on at
syracuse and
and and i said wow look this with
experiments you don't
always know the result and and they can
be wrong
you have to be sure and uh it was it was
a big big experience but it also showed
me
that that you have to be very very
careful with
knowing what you claim and being assured
of what
you claim and being able to defend it in
a meeting like these wars
so without a bit of a background maybe
we should actually
have you say what gravitational waves
are just that we're
starting on the same page so yeah
it was a time when almost nobody had
heard of gravitational wave except for
mathematical physicists
but the way i like to imagine
gravitational waves
is is emotion a vibration of this
jello that we live in which is space
time
and space time i like to draw it i'm not
very good at drawing but
you know if you have a three-dimensional
grid
uh where you use like like a grid paper
but in three dimensions
but all the distances are the same and
you imagine clocks in all the corners
that are
all synchronized that's flat space time
now imagine that space time with the
clocks
and the distances all oscillating
that's a gravitational wave and it
it is uh it is easy to imagine it in
that way what's difficult to imagine and
that's what einstein calculated
just less than a year after publishing
his theory of relativity with this space
time is that
masses are the ones that distort
space-time
so that makes space time curved so it
was
moving masses the ones that could
produce
gravitational waves right
yeah so so so again just for the benefit
of everyone around us you're making
reference to the key
idea of general relativity that masses
warp or curve this fabric of space now
you're saying if the masses are moving
around
space-time is going to be doing like
this and 1916 einstein writes a paper
on the possibility that these
gravitational waves might be
one of the implications of his general
theory of relativity he made a little
mistake as i recall
good one but yes yeah 1918 he writes
another paper
correct some of those mistakes but
einstein himself
and again correct me if i'm wrong but
einstein himself was
on the fence for
i mean and he had the right to be if in
his 1916 paper
he didn't say that gravitational waves
were impossible to
to detect but and it's german so
different people
translated differently but he said given
the constants in the theory and the
constants are
newton's constant and the speed of light
when you calculate
what magnitude these gravitational waves
could have
he didn't put numbers but he said they
were negligible
yeah yeah yeah they're good encryption
so so so joe weber you mentioned these
bars and i gathered these bars of these
big
chunks of metal that in principle for
gravitational wave were to roll by
would jiggle us it caused that metal to
oscillate in some way
weber joe webber was claiming that he'd
measure those oscillations
in that perhaps tense conversation at
that meeting you're describing between
weber and kip thorne the possibility
that weber
was confused or not interpreting
whatever signal he was finding
accurately was raised
so so the issue was completely open at
that point could
we build a new kind of detector
that might have the sensitivity to truly
measure these ripples in the fabric of
space and time
um so that inspires what ultimately
turns into
ligo laser interferometer gravitational
wave observatory
what's the new idea for how you might
detect these gravitational waves that
ultimately yields ligo
interference interference and this was
an idea
that that had been around in the 70s
not just in the u.s but in the u.s and
europe
of using interferometers instead of the
bars
what happens is that the distances
between the atoms change
and that excites the resonance frequency
of the burn and then if you motion
if you measure the motion of the bar
then you would detect gravitational
waves
but in interference the idea is using
interference or interferometers
to measure how distances change and this
is something
interference and lasers is something
that is used in general to measure
distances very precisely and distance
and also motion
changes in distance fluctuations in
distance and interferometers are among
the most precise
instruments is what distances
would you need to measure what changes
is what you need to measure
that's right and this is one thing i
find amazing in in looking at the
history of this
like i said this history started in the
70s 80s when people began thinking about
that
and they had this magic number in mind
that was
uh 10 to the minus 21. uh that is that
the
amplitude of gravitational waves that's
something we haven't said but it's
important that the amplitude of
gravitational waves even though
they are changes in distance they don't
have units of
meters or centimeters or they don't have
units of distance because the longer the
distance you measure
then the larger the fractional
the change in distance so the fractional
change is constant
and that is the amplitude of the
gravitational wave
and that fractional change that was
estimated
that you needed to distinguish to
measure
to really measure be sensitive to
astrophysical
gravitational waves it was clear that
you could not produce gravitational
waves on earth that you could measure
because those changes would be a parting
10 to the 40 or so
so that's impossible but people thought
to me if i had been hearing that it
would have sounded
almost as impossible that departing 10
to the 21 you could measure
now to most people listening you know
one part and 10 to the 21 one part and
10 to the 40.
both sound pretty astoundingly difficult
but but you actually have a little
animation i guess of uh interferometer
that yeah
or the basic idea of how laser light
and it's that's right
and then it bounces on mirrors so the
light comes back
and then we measure the two beams coming
from the two different arms
interfering at the output that's why we
call it interferometer
and if the two distances are the same
then the interference at the output is
destructive there's no light coming out
but if those distances change and that's
what the gravitational wave would do
it's a quadrupolar gravitational wave so
it would make
one distance shorter than the other one
longer then the interference
wouldn't be destructive anymore so if we
put a photocell at the output of the
interferometer
and measure how much light there is and
we see more light less light more light
less light
then we would be able to say there's
something
changing those distances one with
respect to the other
so when was the when was the first of
these of these ligo
detectors built well it depends on what
you mean by lego detectors there were
prototypes
that were prototypes and those
prototypes actually
had a sensitivity that was
uh of the la
sorry let me refresh the ligo detectors
are
four kilometers long there are two of
these one in louisiana and that's why i
live in louisiana very close to one of
those although i cannot go there now
i wish i could um and then
the other one in in the northwest in
washington state they are
four kilometers long a part in 10 to the
21
of four kilometers long is
410 to the minus 18 meters which is
four parts in a thousand of a proton
diameter
it's no it's less than an atom it's less
than a proton
it's four parts in a thousand of a
proton diameter
so it's like measuring sub-nuclear
distances there are lots of tricks we
don't measure some nuclear
particles we measure interference but
that 10 to the minus 18 meters
had been closely close to that
had been achieved in some prototypes
before ligo and that's why people
thought it was it was possible you just
have to make it
longer because these prototypes were not
shorter than
last size or 40 meters now many many
years went by
without seeing signals say in the in the
first
official version of ligo that was that
how many how many years did ligo one
operate without success well
this is also something that's also very
interesting history and very admirable
history of the
well ray wise and keep thorn who were
the ones proposing this but also the
national science foundation because
in the proposal sent to nsf for the
funding of these two observatories
in the late 80s it was approved funded
in 1992
um they said that the
there was the observatories needed to be
four kilometers long
uh and that that was going to the
technology that was going to be
uh installed in that was probably not
going to be enough
to get the sensitivity needed that a
second phase was going to be needed so
it was known
from the beginning that we would have
probably have to work on this
for a long time but it was almost a
question of
when not weathered for us
and we did um operate this initial
version of
initial ligo detectors between 2000 and
2010
only in 2005 was when we actually
achieved the sensitivity that we wanted
which was 10 to the minus 21 by the
noise so we couldn't see a signal there
not yet so we'll get to the the the
first
signal in in just a moment for those of
you who are just joining let me just
note that i'm
have the pleasure of speaking with
gabriella gonzalez from ligo we're
talking about gravitational waves and
now and then i will go to the questions
of the folks who are watching let me
just do one quick one if it's okay with
you
now gabby sam banner asks do gravitation
waves affect
only space or do they also affect time
if they do affect time how do they
affect
time they do affect time just as much as
they do affect space
when we think about the distances
oscillating those clocks that are
also getting out of sync by a parting 10
to the 21.
so that's also taken into account as you
look for the various signals that that
might come forward
any other there are a bunch of other
questions that i see that was the most
relevant to gravitational waves i'm
going to focus on those kinds of
questions first
and then after after we conclude our
conversation i'll we'll deal with any
questions that you want but now let's
turn
to the success right so this
is now uh september of 2015.
my understanding is that the ligo
collaboration had done a lot of work to
upgrade the sensitivity of the detector
beyond ligo one to the levels
that now in principle would be able to
detect uh the typical gravitational wave
that
one might imagine being generated by
some distant astrophysical phenomenon
and then comes september 14th
so what happens on september 14th of
2015
yeah well let me say that in 2015
2014 actually was when we first had
light going back and forth
in these detectors having them
operational
but not even close to the sensitivity we
wanted
we still don't have the sensitivity we
want
uh and in 20 and we had been planning
from the beginning that if we were not
going to wait until getting
we were not going to be perfectionist
around 2015 we were going we were
planning to be
three four times better than we had been
before instead of ten times better
that's what we wanted that's what we
want
um and then we would take data for a few
months
we were not expecting to see anything
because this 10 to the -21 we had
learned
was actually a big big amplitude it was
not going to be common and we were
looking at signals we were counting on
signals produced by
binary neutral star systems because
there are
several of those binary neutral star
systems
known in our galaxy and we know they
coalesce no coalescence had been seen
but
we knew that even given enough time
millions or hundreds of millions of
years they would call us so if we could
see them further
then we would see those but we didn't
have the sensitivity that we
we needed uh in 2015 for doing that but
we had planned that we were going to
take data and i
am on record saying and who knows there
might be black holes out there
they would have to be close they would
have to be big but
who knows and rather than a neutron star
dance
a black hole dance would create a bigger
a bigger signal
which in principle ligo the advanced
version would be able to
attack but predictions were very very
uncertain because if you have two black
holes they don't produce light
they might be dancing at tango like i
like to say being from argentina but
they don't produce light they produce
gravitational waves but don't lie
we know about black holes from x-rays
because they
sometimes are close to another star and
then the particles that are
that are traveling to the black hole
from the other star they produce x-rays
so we know we knew that we knew black
holes existed
right we didn't know we didn't think
they were very big
except the ones at the center of
galaxies millions of
mass solar masses but these black holes
were usually 10 solar masses
or less so those
would have to be very close and but like
you said
on september 14 we were preparing for
taking data we were not there
yet because we wanted to have an
automated system of alerts which was not
ready yet we wanted to be able
to simulate gravitational waves pushing
the mirrors in the interferometer
so that we could test our algorithms and
we had not
found yet the way to simulate
gravitational waves the way we wanted
so we had delayed the start of the run
for a couple of weeks
and it was in that period when we were
getting ready
that at night when the interferometers
were operational but we were not
doing tests we were taking data to
practice the
data the data algorithms and
and one of those algorithms posted a
webpage
having a candidate that was amazing
right so you were just at this point
you're just setting up
you know you're just sort of unpacking
metaphorically the equipment
and taking off the lab your outside coat
to put on the lab coat metaphor it's
just sort of the warm-up stage that's
right
and all of a sudden there's this big
signal
and the big signal was in both of the
detectors it was in baltic
thursday it was uh 5 am in livingston
3 am in in hanford it was very early in
the morning so except for the operators
on shift
everybody else was sleeping well people
in europe were not sleeping
right so when you first saw this did you
think uh
glitch did you think sabotage
you know what like the first thing we
thought it was a simulation
because we had been people had been
practicing these simulations and
we were all thinking why didn't they
write it in the electronic logs because
we have a public electronic log when we
publish
what we put all the things we are doing
in the interferometer
and but but simulation
a simulation is like how does that work
does someone actually
program the machine to shake a little
bit i mean
yes actually we we produce a computer
simulation of a gravitational wave
or we take an approximation of a
gravitational wave
then we calculate what forces we
we choose the direction in the sky
and then we choose we we calculate
what motion the mirrors would have to
have
different in each detector uh in
livingston and hanford
and then we push the mirrors to to prove
uh
to uh produce that motion simulating a
gravitational wave
yeah so you figured that you know we do
we call these hardware injections
because sometimes we do software
injections we
when we add a simulated signal to the
calibrated data
so in this case it's hardware because we
do push the mirrors
actually push the mirrors so you assume
that somebody on the team
had come up with an interesting
simulation programmed it in
and forgot to log it in the electronic
logs and then
so presumably you start to ask people
hey
did you put that simulation in
that not only that but we also looked uh
when when these simulations are done we
have uh
we have channels we don't only record
the output of the interferometer in the
photos and we also
record how much force we put on the
mirrors
there are tons and tons and tons of
channels that we
that we store on disk to know what
happens with interferometer
and with environment magnetometer
seismometers everything
and and we could look in those channels
and see that nobody had
there was no push right were you at all
worried
that there might have been some
prankster graduate student
who might have you know programmed this
in to get you all
excited and not recorded any of it and
then
after an announcement is made you know
it becomes clear that this was actually
just a fake
signal that was that question we didn't
worry about that
well we worried about that a lot but in
the beginning i mean after i
asked a few people and a few people i
know well so
i knew how to read the answers i knew
that that now it wasn't
and like i said we had evidence in we
had no evidence in the channels that
this had been an injection like the ones
we planned
yeah uh but also what what we
were most worried about is that we
didn't
have enough data to know what the noise
of the detector looked like
because we have not taken any data yet
right
right so we really needed data
to know what the noise was like and
know whether this coincidence perfect as
it looked
was statistically significant i say i
say
and that was going to take a while i i'd
assumed
this is very interesting i'd assume that
between september
when the signal came in or the purported
signal came in
and february when you guys actually were
confident enough to make the big
announcement
i assume that most of that period was
interrogating people uh you know look at
the signal in detail but actually you
needed that
period of time to measure the
steady state noise of the detector
itself to be able to subtract that out
from the purported signal to see whether
what was left was
significant or not at that point that's
right yeah we don't subtract the signal
to see whether
what we have noise it's we we do a
statistical analysis
you will see in the in that discovery
paper that we had a histogram
showing all the coincidences that we see
between interferometers that we know are
not astrophysical
because we we cannot shield
astrophysical signals
like you would do in a lab experiment
but
uh what we do is we look for the time
coincidences
that when we shift the time in a
detector we analyze the data the same
way we analyze it for real
but we say well the gps time in hanford
it's going to be the gps
plus three com 3.5 seconds by
10.2 seconds and then we know that any
coincidence will not be astrophysicals
because
there's only 10 millisecond light travel
time between the two detectors
right right so the to show that these
all came from the same source
that same source is going to hit
louisiana and washington state at
slightly different moments and you're
ensuring that
it's compatible with your understanding
of how fast that's right
and that first signal had seven
milliseconds uh
different time difference first arrived
in louisiana we always like to say
here right right seven milliseconds
later in hanford
now you also are doing presumably
supercomputer
simulations at this moment because the
signal has a very specific
shape in fact you you have a picture of
the signal from
from september 14th don't you have a
graphic
yeah it doesn't have the simulation
superimposed this
is actually the signal from the
photodiodes
at hanford in orange and livingstone
in blue and we have shifted it's shifted
because the handful data is shifted by
seven milliseconds notice that this is
only a
fraction of a second and notice the peak
amplitude is 10 to the minus 21
exactly wow and and you can see this
sine wave that
increases in amplitude and frequency
that's as the two black holes we
from the frequency we could tell that
these were black holes that were
uh moving faster and faster together
until they coalesce and they coalesce
they form a bigger black hole that rings
down
and then you don't see anymore because
the final black hole does not produce
gravitational waves
i see so the left hand side of that
image
are the black holes rapidly spinning
again
around each other then they smash into
each other they coalesce that gives you
the big
right and then there is a little ring
down two or three cycles and then
it just goes away it noise you can see
noise i mean of course we don't see a
flat line and then a gravitational wave
we always have
noise in the detector and you see noise
in the beginning and at the end
now now to understand precisely
who was dancing the tango that you
described earlier
that's where the super computer
simulations come into the story i gather
because you
can take the theory of einstein's
general theory take the equations
and you can say okay let me imagine that
there's a black hole of mass
10 solar masses and another of 13 put
that into the simulation and get one
particular signal or let me put one in
the
22 solar masses and 18 and you can get
another signal out of the mathematics
so you already had presumably a whole
library
of wave shapes associated with all
manner of astrophysical vision out there
and so when you match that shape against
that library what conclusion
do you draw for who's dancing the tango
out there that's how we can get
the masses of the black holes
we can infer something not very not very
well but we can infer something about
the spin of the black holes the final
mass which is not the sum of the masses
these black holes had 129 solar masses
the other one 36
and the sun had 62.
and i know your audience is very
literate so they will say that's wrong
it's not wrong
the rest was energy emitted in
gravitational waves e equal
equal and c squared formula so the lost
mass from the from the union you're
saying
is transmuted transformed
into this energy of the gravitational
wave of the last
the last bit of the gravitational waves
yes
you were talking about supercomputer
simulations supercomputer simulations
actually
it was a big big um
victory when they could simulate
gravitational waves produced by black
holes i remember that
in the initial ligo era there were no
yet results from black hole there were
only head-on collisions but not this
dance
and we didn't we hadn't detected
gravitational waves
and there was a bit of a race that we're
going to see them first or are you going
to calculate them first they calculated
them
in i think it was in 2005 but
yeah so there have been a lot of
progress in that but they're still
very very expensive so we don't have a
library
of super computer simulations what we do
have
is very good approximations formulas
phenomenological formulas
where we can put the masses and we test
the validity of those formulas against
supercomputer simulations and then we
use these formulas to make these
libraries so it's a
big uh effort by numerical relativity
people
by analytical relativity people by
experimental
and so on because in the conversation
that we had a while ago at the world
science festival ray weiss
was part of that conversation one of the
striking things of that conversation was
the fact that ligo went forward before
it was certain that the supercomputer
simulations could even be achieved
because without them you'd get some
signal
but interpreting that signal would be
virtually impossible
without being able to calculate what the
signal should look like
based upon einstein's general theory of
relativity
so you know in my tradition we would
call that incredible hutzpah
to go forward with an experiment of this
magnitude with so many people and so
much money
with the hope borne out but with the
hope at that early time
that the theory would catch up or as you
say even win the race
to uh to calculate these things was
there a time when you were worried
that maybe we won't be able to calculate
these things and we'll have this machine
and maybe they'll be sick
and we'll scratch our heads saying
that's an interesting looking signal but
i don't know what it is well to be fair
these simulations are essential
to uh to see the validity of these
formulas for signals that are
so short but like i said before the
the one signal the one population that
we were sure existed out there
even though it was more difficult to
detect than black holes but we knew they
were out there it was these binary
neutral star systems
and binary neutron star systems uh
in this they take a longer dance uh in
the detector
and this part of this of the wave where
you see the amplitude
and the frequency increasing before the
merger
that is very well approximated by
perturbative methods
so that part was well known the problem
is that for black holes
that part shrinks to one or two cycles
and then you then you're not sure for
that you do
need computers
so so it all it all worked out the
computers uh
and the algorithms to run on those
computers were developed
um at what point between september of
2015 and february
were you pretty sure that this was
a collision between out there in space
well uh i think we were sure that
we had a great candidate
when we took data we took data for about
a month which is what we calculated we
needed we were going to take data for
four months and we kept taking data but
we analyzed the data for about a month
at 15 effectively 15 days of coincident
data between the two detectors
and in there we looked at the statistics
and it was good
i mean this was a very very significant
candidate
but from those preliminary calculations
we didn't have simulations we didn't
have the parameter estimation quite yet
in fact
we have not finished reviewing all the
codes that we used to do these things so
we have to do the two things in parallel
but from those preliminary observations
as i mentioned the
masses of the black holes 29 and 36
solar passes
were huge compared to the masses that
were known so
this one actually was very strange
we really needed to be sure and like i
said we hadn't
finished reviewing the course which we
had wanted to do before we started
taking later
you know everything runs late so that
took us
months and also at the same time we
began looking for alternative
explanations we
had to rule everything out we had a team
of people
looking into possibly hacking
and we realized from the outside world
yeah
yeah and we realized that we couldn't
completely discard that possibility
but it would have to be they wouldn't
put signals in the
the way we usually push the mirrors they
would have had to
uh to put some extra electronics and do
extra simulations
and do it simultaneously at the two
observatories
without everybody knowing uh you know we
have
cards to know where people are at what
time so they would have to bypass
everything
so it would have to be have been at
least four or five
insiders very very insiders and
we just didn't believe that was we don't
believe that
that's happened so you so what did it
feel like
when you finally had that confidence i
mean you look back
i mean it's einstein general relativity
1915
1916 he proposes that there might be
these gravitational waves revises that
in 1918
you know people start to build these
devices through like the 50s and 60s
but now the first moment of success
right i mean that's like what what you
dream about
right i mean what was that feeling like
well
i have to say that uh i was at the time
the spokesperson of the
ligo scientific collaboration i'm not
anymore actually these are two year
positions i had three i said
three terms until 2017 but i was
delivered at the time
so from the beginning i have to say that
i
lived in a state of panic well not panic
but but
but stressful energy it was boring
boring boring everything and about
things
the right things to be happening the
paper to be written
and all the checks to be done and
we were also very worried because if we
had
seen this gravitational wave before even
trying
why didn't we see another when we
analyzed that amount of data
some of us thought that we were going to
see more than one but it was
only an indication of a second one that
could be real with
one question later on we confirmed it
with better analysis
um but we didn't see another one so
until we saw another one i have to say
that we felt uncomfortable
and in december we saw another one
it was not as strong but it was longer
so in significance it was also very
significant
we didn't have the analysis complete by
the time we made the announcement but
we were all breathing a bit easier
because we
knew that was it was not just a single
example
there was more of that so was there a
point when
the um the tension eased and you could
just
revel in you know it was
two days after the announcement we made
the announcement on
thursday february 11 i remember
yeah which by the way was the first time
that was celebrate that the
international day of women and girls in
science was celebrated
that is celebrated now every february 11
it was destinated like that by the u.n
and but that was the first february 11
and
there were two women among the five
scientists on the podium
all of this is a coincidence but then
the next day friday there were lots of
interviews i was talking at the
conference the
triple a yes conference the american
american association for the advancement
of science
so it was the president of argentina
called me
obama tweeted it was
i mean there was so much excitement that
i was stealing this
adrenaline field stage
and then the next day i i actually
woke up in the hotel still in washington
and i i cried this is
this was it this is it that's fantastic
yeah no it's it's it's it's i mean
physics is not often viewed as
an emotional subject in the classroom
but to a scientist like yourself
who makes a discovery that will be
remembered
for you know eons to come
yeah it's an emotional moment so your
reaction is
i think really indicative of why we do
what we do
it's for those of you
but of course the announcement was was
huge it was
important but what we knew then is that
this was the beginning yeah because we
didn't have we knew we could improve the
sensitivity we were already
working on that we knew now that black
holes binary black holes existed
in more than one there was there have
been more than one
so we knew we were going to discover
more and more things and we have been
doing that so that's why we turned why
don't we turn to that
now last part of our conversation i mean
what has happened
uh since this discovery back in 20 years
in 2016. well we let me say that we
talked about the ligo collaboration
making this discovery but actually it
was two collaborations the ligo
collaboration and the vigo collaboration
the big collaboration
is a european collaboration of
scientists that has a detector in italy
the virgo detector
a three kilometer detector and we in the
initial ligo era
we had agreed to work together we had
taken data together we had not
discovered gravitational waves together
uh but we were working in the analysis
together so that first discovery paper
was signed by both collaborations and in
2000
so we and the the earth detector was not
operational
uh yet but in 2016 in november 2016 we
began taking data again with the ligo
detectors and the vehicle detector was
going to be ready in a few months
actually ended up being ready in august
of 2017 and we were going to take data
until the end of august 2017. so it was
only one month
of the of that we took data together but
in those months
we detected seven coalescences of
black holes seven more so with the other
three were 10
we would have 10 mark already
some of these with vivo 2 so we had good
localization because we could
triangulate
and on august 17
all was running out of time in this
observing run
we saw finally a collision of neutron
stars
i see and those collision of neutron
stars that collision because we were
taking it
together with vigo we could triangulate
and moreover we could be sure it was
neutral stars and not small black holes
because there had been a detection of
gamma rays coincident with
our detection and that had been posted
online
an alert at the same time we had posted
hours
actually before we posted hours so we
knew that there had been light coming
electromagnetic waves coming from this
event
so we told astronomers we had lots of
agreements with astronomers they looked
there
and they found first a red spot then a
blue spot
and then on blue and then red i forget
and 10 days late later x-rays
and and radio waves it was amazing that
was one of the
best objects started in astronomy
and so by triangulate you're saying if
on planet earth
we've say got three locations that
detect the gravitational waves from a
single source
by virtue of the time differences
of the arrival of the signatures you can
pinpoint
where in the sky the signal that's right
because with two detectors they are like
microphones
so you don't actually see the um
you cannot tell where they come from
from the time difference into detectors
you can tell well it comes from a wing
in the sky
and by looking at the bit more data
amplitudes and faces you can say well it
comes from that
banana piece we call the bananas in the
sky
but with three detectors then you have
uh
two pairs of those bananas so you have
an intersection
and that intersection is a little circle
or a little wager not little for
astronomers it's not a small region
it's more than a full moon but but still
it was enough for people to go and and
look in there and they looked at
galaxies and known galaxies and in one
of those galaxies they discovered this
bright spot that hadn't been there
before fantastic
but that was 2017. then we improved even
more the detectors we took
we began to take data again in 2019
last year in april first full day
and then we were planning to take data
with vidco from the beginning
and we were planning to take data until
the end of april we had to stop at the
end of march because of the pandemic
but we have been analyzing that data we
actually had public alerts you could get
an app i had two apps in my phone
that sound and alert and those are
public apps because the alerts were
public so you could tag when they listen
we had 56 alerts 56
candidates of gravitational waves
11 months almost 11 months you're saying
that anybody can have this app and they
can be alerted when when a new candidate
for gravitational waves that's
that's that's right that's right
and so some of those alerts and
subsequent confirmations have yielded
some surprises
uh yes yes actually
like i said the candidates take a while
into being confirmed so we actually have
the alert
we classified whether it's most likely
binary black hole
or a neutral star black hole and we have
several candidates of that kind
or a binary neutron star and and we have
published now
about four different candidates four
different detections not candidates
anymore
that are confirmed as gravitational
waves and we have published those on
on their own uh we are going to publish
a catalog but we published
those on their own because they are all
very interesting
one is them some of the masses of the
black holes are surprising
right well the first detection had
surprising masses
but then in that catalog of ten uh black
hole coil essences in one and o two
that's how we call observation run so
one and o two where the first two o
three is this last one
uh we had uh the maximum mass we had had
of a
black hole was uh was close to
eighty 80 solar masses from the merger
of two
but indeed in the latest one we have
confirmed that it had made it to the
papers it was
it appeared in lots of media had
two big black holes 165
solar masses they added 80 some solar
masses
that formed 142 solar masses
and these black holes this big
are are in a region of masses of black
holes
that some astrophysical theorists say
they cannot exist actually but they say
that's what the new media says what they
say
is that they cannot be formed from
an ex supernova explosion which is how
we believe black holes are formed in
supernova explosions that leave behind
the neutral star or the black hole but
if they do
they have a maximum mass because masses
that are bigger than that don't explode
this way
so there is a maximum mass for black
holes to be formed this way
and both of these black holes are larger
than that mass
especially the bigger one so the
speculation is
that these black holes or at least one
of those was probably formed by the
merger of two other black holes so it's
sort of a sequence a cascade
there may be some initial supernova
gives you a black hole of a given mass
and then these guys perhaps underground
and then that performs another one but
that means that there are a lot that
these black holes are clustered
because all that they have there are a
lot more of these
we don't know yet oftentimes people ask
me they say well you're always talking
about binary black holes what about
the trinary are you are you do you ever
i mean
i guess in principle you've never seen
anything like that presumably yet or
well this could have been one we haven't
seen
it to see one what you would need to see
is the coalescence of the office black
hole
and in the perturbations of the signal
see the indications of the third black
hole
still there or the third mass but for
that you would need a lot of definition
on that waveform to see those small
perturbations
so so what is next and i i mean that
really in
in two in two ways one is what are the
new detectors that are going to
hopefully be built to increase the
sensitivity in the manner you suggest
but the other
question and maybe just take them
together separately as you see fit
the the promise of gravitational waves
has often been we're going to see some
things that we expect
like neutron star collisions or black
hole mergers or
which are spectacular but oftentimes
those
descriptions are concluded by saying and
the most exciting thing
is that we're going to see things that
no one ever anticipated
that's right so so where do you where do
you stand
on on that so first of all what's the
new what's the new equipment new
technology that
you hope to be built in say the next 10
20 30 years
well we still have improvements to make
to the technology that we have in these
facilities so we can still get a lot
more of these facilities but if we
really want that factor of 10
which is what we did from initial ligo
to advanced ligo
if we wanted the next factor of 10 which
would give us
all the black holes in the universe we
could tell the story the history the
cosmological history of black holes
uh it would tell us it would give us
most of the neutral stars the lord of
neutral stars with the
sensing the the precision we need to do
nuclear physics nuclear physics
out there in the universe imagine that
to do that we
we really need new facilities bigger
facilities
new technology and that technology is
being developed
cryogenics and new materials and new
lasers
but you really need facilities that are
bigger 10 kilometers 40 kilometers there
are different designs
uh the international community is
putting is
working together on this because these
would
of course be very expensive too so they
would have to be international
collaborations no single country could
do this
and this would be space-based i mean
lisa is the experiment that many people
point toward is that that's right well i
was telling
you about our ground-based detectors to
detect
all of these compact smaller compact
objects but
if you want to see bigger black holes
like the ones at the center of galaxies
then you need to go to space and that's
lisa
it has it is actually not a project
anymore it has decided it has a launch
day
2034 so it's still a few years away
you know running you say 2034 my first
thought is to calculate
what's the likelihood i'm gonna still be
here but uh you know
that that's how these that's how this
progress is maybe do you have a picture
do you have a picture of a prototype for
lisa in your
yes in the last slide uh it's a small
picture but it also shows you the full
spectrum i think
yes yeah good i see it so on the on the
right at the bottom right
there's the ground-based interferometers
we see collisions of solar mass black
holes intermediate mass black holes may
be
and neutron stars with a space detector
lisa it's a triangular detector we see
here one satellite but it's actually
three satellites with the light
it doesn't go back and forth we have
lasers one laser in each station that
points to the
other to the other station these would
be two and a half
million kilometers away
and they would detect gravitational
waves from not just these massive black
holes at the center of galaxies but also
white dwarfs in our galaxies that we
know exist
and produce gravitational waves in fact
we could use some of those as
calibrators
right and then you want to go bigger you
want to see
super massive black holes and in fact
there's so many of those that they would
produce like a noisy background a
stochastic background
and those for those you have to go
galactic not space but galactic
and that is being done with what we call
pulsar timing that uses the
radio waves that we see from pulsars
from neutral stars in our galaxy we know
about them because we detect radius
signals from these
and and from looking at the correlations
of these radio signals is like an
interferometer the laser is the radio
wave
and and this is has been going on
and my day is that the next instrument
to detect gravitational waves is going
to be
that that technique really yeah
i've been hearing about that yeah i've
been hearing about that for a long long
time it always sounded so incredibly
exciting but you think that's on the
cusp
of uh yes wow
and and oftentimes when talking about
gravitational waves
people make reference to primordial
gravitational waves from the big bang
itself not
not detecting the waves of phenomena
within
the environment that we can sort of feel
is there but even going right back
to the beginning is that what's the
likelihood of that kind of a success
oh i think it's also likely to be seen
in a different way for that you don't
use interference this this early
universe had gravitational waves
uh like the cosmic microwave background
and it is a background it's like a noisy
because it's not
waves of a single frequency or any
particular frequencies these waves at
all
frequencies all mixed together and it is
calculated it depends on the
cosmological model so different
inflation models have different
predictions
but the predictions they have certainly
for
for the lease of sensitivity for
frequencies in the lisa band or in the
ligo band
it's we are just not going to see that
it's going to be hidden
by other sources astrophysical sources
like both
white dwarfs and lisa or or black holes
in in ligo
but you could see there is a prediction
that those gravitational waves polarized
that cosmic microwave background in a
very particular manner
and if you can measure the polarization
of the microwave background which is
being done at the
at the moment but if you can measure it
precisely enough
and you can tell that the polarization
is not
caused by the dust in the way
which has been the case so far then you
can say
this is a snapshot of gravitational
waves
imprinted in that cosmic microwave
background
and there has been i mean there was a an
announcement of success that
i guess uh yes apparently had to be uh
re-uh reinterpreted perhaps as the yeah
just like new to dust but those
experiments are getting more and more
sensitive all the time so that's
also maybe some point let me just
one question from uh the audience before
we
conclude here so uh shanti chandrasekhar
asks do gravitational waves
interfere with each other
in principle yes but what we call
interference
is between two waves that have the same
frequency like they are produced by a
coherent
source and we don't think that stars
or black holes get in touch with each
other
to to produce to be coherent one with
each other so that would not be the case
however that would happen if we were to
see
length gravitational waves we could have
an object
far away like a coalescence a black hole
binary
system that produces gravitational waves
and there could be something
really big very very well aligned in the
line of sight it would have to be
incredibly well aligned with the line of
sight
and then that would distort the
gravitational waves going through
that are coming from the same source so
they would be coherent with each other
and then they would last when arriving
to earth
so in that case uh you could call that
interference
we call it lensing we haven't seen any
evidence yet
uh we cannot discard it completely but
from the statistics that we have
uh we these these lensing events are
very very rare because you need
that incredible alignment but that would
be a case of interference
right so so for yourself do you see
sticking with gravitational waves uh for
uh
for the duration of your career or yeah
so much more to do i i work mostly and
my group works mostly
on the instruments uh these days on
diagnosing trying to clean up the data
because the data is
very glitchy the background that they
produce especially for black holes is
is big so we want to we want to be able
to make to to diagnose where the noises
come the glitches are coming from
and and remove them from the data but i
have also
been involved and my and my group has
been involved in the commissioning
and the improvement of sensitivity of
the detectors
and there's so much to do we also are
involved in
in the discussions of future detectors
which i i hope to i hope to see in my
lifetime but i
know they take decades uh to build so
it's never late to start we are already
working on that
well you know you've already uh hit the
pinnacle
you know you know one of the discoveries
that will be remembered as a
as a high point of science in our era
so uh anything else that you achieve of
course is spectacular icing on the cake
it's a sort of great position to be in
so
so you know obviously congratulations on
you know the achievement well deserved
and
the continuing success of the
collaboration and
and finding unexpected things about the
nature of the universe through the
detection of gravitational waves
uh thanks so much uh for spending the
time
here with us today the audience uh so
appreciative of
you know hearing directly from people
like yourself who are on the
on the front lines of pushing the
boundary of understanding so
gabriella gonzalez thanks so much for
joining us and i look forward to
future discoveries that will provide
future
material for conversations going forward
so thank you very much for joining us
thank you thank you for hosting this
because
i think that one of the advantages one
of the few advantages of a pandemic like
this
is realizing ourselves that
we can take advantage of this of this
media
to talk about science even though we
cannot be together in the same room
you know hugely so i mean in the program
that that we did
back in 2015 or 16 whatever 15 i guess
it was
you know on general relativity and the
po it must have been the possibility of
gravitational waves at that point yes
i gave a lecture in world science
university yeah
exactly and and those you know i mean
those are some of our
you know millions of people have viewed
you know some of the conversations that
we've had there so
it is a service that many people make
use of so
i think you're absolutely right there's
a way in which we can make use of this
medium to really
uh get people excited about the power of
science
about the excitement of discovery and
maybe combat
some of the sentiment that we feel
trickling down
from arenas of government that
at least uh some of us hope will shift
on november 3rd
but we'll leave that leave that
conversation for a different day we'll
stay in the realm of science here for
now
so again thanks for joining us and uh
look forward to interacting with you
at some point again in the future thank
you
all right folks so we're gonna now um
move on to uh
focusing on and some of the questions
that are
coming in on uh on youtube
uh so let me just
[Music]
see what else we have here uh so uh
priyanashu shukla hello sir brian what
advice
do you have for those who are aspiring
to become physicists yeah i love that's
a sort of a fun question to start
look the advice is simple get inspired
by the kind of conversation that we just
had get inspired by seeing
the kinds of discoveries that are
still with us today right there can be a
sense that
the big questions of physics have been
settled in an earlier era
and there's not much left to do but
there's a huge amount left to do you
just heard from
gabriella gonzalez about the spectacular
insights
in gravitational physics from
gravitational waves their spectacular
insights
still awaiting us in the realms of
quantum mechanics cosmology particle
physics
so my advice to the young aspiring
physicist is to become
excited about the possibility
of contributing to those endeavors but
at the same time
focusing your studies on the very basics
that you need and you will rely upon
if you go into physics so the basics of
classical mechanics of quantum mechanics
of statistical mechanics of
thermodynamics
of the general theory of relativity of
quantum field there i mean learn
the basic subjects that you will
encounter as an undergraduate and a
graduate student learn
that basic material inside out do not
somehow feel you can skirt around that
material and jump right to the frontier
of
understanding it just doesn't work that
way so buckle down
work hard do your problem sets and get
inspired by
these kinds of conversations that you
can find all over
the internet i mean i'm partial
obviously to the material that we
produce world science u
world science festival excuse me but
there's a lot of great stuff out there
and in your off moments explore
that kind of material but in your own
moments that in the moments that are
dedicated to your own education
do not skimp on learning the basics
that that to me is always the big lesson
for for all of these ideas
uh rob b asked dr green what do you
think about the likelihood of time
being a particle uh it's hard to exactly
interpret that statement so
i guess what i would say is i think
there's a high likelihood the time
and space as we describe them in the
general theory of relativity
as we describe them in the conversation
with gabriella gonzalez that
space is sort of like this fabric she
used the metaphor of jello
that the jello of space can vibrate
it can shake that i think is a is a
is a good metaphor but most of us
believe that quantum mechanically space
and time
are not really fully articulated
as a fabric or a jello that's a
description that works on sufficiently
large distance scales but if you get to
very small distance scales
it's likely that there is something like
an atomic structure
to space and an atomic structure to time
by that i mean
there's some kind of entity fundamental
entity that might be called
the most basic quanta of space or the
most basic quanta of time just like a
photon
is the most basic quanta of the
electromagnetic field
so the gravitational field itself
probably has a graviton
and that graviton itself may give us a
clue
to what the most basic structure of
space and time
actually is and i think at that point we
won't be talking about
a fabric we won't be talking about a
jello
we will be talking about some
fundamental quantum ingredient
and you can think of it as a particle as
you'd like whether that
turns out to be the right language i
don't know but i would say there is
something else
the fabric itself is made of something
finer
and that finer entity is what we're
still
searching for both theoretically and
hopefully
at some point in the future
experimentally
okay i'm just going to scroll through
the
questions that are coming in right now
so if you asked a question earlier you
might want to ask it again because
the list of questions is just too long
for me to uh scroll
through all of them but let me see what
else
we uh we have here um
so blue french horn dr green what is
hawking's no boundary proposal of the
big bang theory
that's a great question a hard one to
answer in words but let me just give you
a feeling for
the idea so normally
we think about space and time as highly
related but
different we think about the
capacity of motion through space
to change your passage through time
that's one of the big insights of
special relativity we recognize that
your location
in space can affect your passage through
time
because if you're near one of those
black holes that
gabriella gonzalez and the ligo
collaboration have now established are
really out there
if you're near the edge of a black hole
einstein's theory
shows us that time slows down so where
you are
in space here or here or here or here
affects your passage through time so
there's this
deep association between space and time
that's really been manifest
since 1905. nevertheless we usually
think about
space and time as still having
certain fundamental differences we can
travel
any which way in space but as far as we
know
we can only travel one way through time
space doesn't have an orientation to it
whether you sort of think about space
this way or that way or that way there's
no
fundamental arrow there's no fundamental
direction for space
but there does appear to be a
fundamental direction a fundamental
arrow
for time the arrow of time seems to
point from the past toward the future
right we ineluctably travel through time
in one direction as far as we know
whereas in space we can travel
any which way there doesn't seem to be a
fundamental direction which is just to
say that space and time
have deep associations they're linked
but we do think about them as different
the hurdle hawking idea
is to imagine that in the early universe
the distinctions between
space and time go away that in the early
universe
time in some sense rotates
into a fourth spatial direction
and that's very interesting because if
the
space-time fabric let me use that
metaphor
really can be thought of as a
four-dimensional
spatial region well four-dimensional
spatial regions they can naturally
smooth off and they can naturally have a
nice smooth end
to them the image that we like to have
in mind is if you think of a cigar
a cigar has a cylindrical shape
and then it has a kind of spherical end
that's attached
to the spherical part of
the cigar so imagine that metaphor
of the cigar could actually apply to
space-time itself so imagine
that as you go further further back in
time you're going along like the
cylindrical part of the cigar
but as you head right back toward the
beginning imagine the time
this direction melds into space
so that they're now all part of a
spatial
region that spatial region can pinch off
like the end of a cigar and in that way
there isn't really an end there isn't
really an
early mo earliest moment it just kind of
smoothly
draws to a conclusion if you will
because of the overall
shape of the space-time fabric and
that's one way of thinking about
the idea that there may
not be an end a unique
end to the space-time fabric instead it
might kind of curve off
and and end in that way so that's
that's an idea that comes from hawking
and hartle and these kinds of ideas we
don't know
if these ideas are right we don't know
if they're wrong but they're interesting
ideas
for thinking about the earliest moments
of
the universe um
physics club asked that 10 to the minus
21 change
due to the waves can change then at
atomic orbits uh well look
you know if you have a gravitational
wave that that rolls by
a region of space in principle
it is deforming the space-time fabric
on all scales right i mean there's a
wavelength associated with that wave but
um any entity in principle is
affected by that stretching and
compressing of the spatial fabric
however small so yes you could
imagine that you
one day if you had sufficient
sensitivity
could detect the kind of stretching and
compressions on
on any scale imaginable so the
ones that we're talking about are are
stretching in compressions that are
on the order of a fraction of a proton
diameter so compared to an atom that's
that's quite small but uh yes in
principle
these kinds of stretching and
compressions one day
they may be commonplace that we can
measure them on all scales which would
uh
be incredibly exciting andrew hanny asks
in the poll and barn paradox so this is
now moving from
general relativity to special relativity
which is fine for us to do
will the pawl will the pole fall
if the barn is replaced by a hole in the
ground that is shorter than the pole
from the poles view
but longer than it from the whole view
so this is andrew this is actually a
well-known paradox i don't i don't
remember
i don't know why i can't remember the
exact name of this particular paradox
but you're right
if you have an object that's say sliding
along a surface
and if that surface has a break in it
where in principle
an object could fall through the surface
like you know
imagine you have a excuse me have a
skateboard
that's going along say a very smooth
straight
track and imagine that there's an
opening in the track
where you could fall right through now
you have a version of the story that you
that you wondered about from the
skateboards point of view it's the track
that's moving
and so the opening will be lorenz
contract and it'll be very small
so from the skateboarders perspective of
course they're not going to fall through
they are longer than the opening which
has now been lorenz contracted
from the person on the track looking at
the skateboard the skateboard is
incredibly
compressed and therefore is much smaller
than the opening
and therefore from the perspective of
somebody on the track this little tiny
skateboard of course it's going to fall
through
the opening and now you have the paradox
andrew that you ask about
from one perspective the skateboard
should not fall through
the perspective of the skateboarder him
or herself
or themself from the perspective of the
person on the track
obviously the skateboard will fall
through
and the answer to your question like
who's right and who's wrong
this is one of those situations where
the details
really matter the details of for
instance
the exact speed and strength of the
material
out of which the skateboard is made
because as you can imagine
there's going to come a point perhaps
from the perspective of those
in the track frame of reference where
the back of the skateboard is still
on the solid surface and the front is
not so
does the material bend does the material
angle downward these kinds of details
actually matter when it comes to
analyzing
this situation so there's no uniform
answer that we can give
it depends on the details the precise
details of how the object is rolling
what it is made of and so forth
so so it is a resolvable
question if the details are specified
but without the details you're left
somewhat
up in the air but bear in mind it is not
a paradox there is an
answer but the answer depends on the
details
so it's a very good question but not one
that can be answered
in generality without specifying those
details
arjun kr says how does the speed of
gravity
become equal to the speed of light
that's interesting we didn't
i guess we did in the conversation with
gabriella gonzalez we did
make use of the fact that the speed of
gravity
is equal to the speed of light which
means that these ripples in the
space-time fabric
they travel from the source to the
receiver
at the speed of light now now why how do
we make use of that we made use of that
recall
that gabby was saying how the time delay
in when the signals were received in
washington
and in louisiana that was an important
piece of the story establishing that
these
gravitational detections were real
because if there's a fixed source in
space
then the distance to louisiana and the
distance to washington state are
slightly different
and therefore if the wave is traveling
at the speed of light you can calculate
the kind of time difference that you
expect between detection
at each of these two locations and the
answer that they got
agreed with the actual measured
difference which was a nice piece of
corroborating evidence that this was
indeed a gravitational wave from a
single source
in in outer space but the question
that's being asked is why is it that the
speed of light
equals the speed of gravity and that's
something that's manifest in einstein's
general
theory of relativity you see directly
that ripples in the fabric of space you
can calculate how fast
they travel and it's a fairly
straightforward almost
one-line calculation in some sense if
you think about it correctly
that there's almost only there's only
one speed in the general theory of
relativity and that is the speed of
light
c appears in the general theory because
the general theory embraces the special
theories of special case
and the special theory we know that the
speed of light is a
natural number that comes into that
story so
it's quite natural that the speed of
gravity is the speed of light and the
general theory of relativity makes that
precise okay a question here that i just
saw
about the size of space uh here it is
ignacio jar gui i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly
how can the universe be infinite if it
had a finite beginning
yeah it's a it's a it's a very good
question because
if you think about the universe
the universe is extent in space
as being finite at the time of the big
bang
then if the big bang happened say 13.8
billion years ago
and if the expansion of space is finite
then a finite stretch of space at the
beginning
would get larger over time but over a
finite time interval 13.8 billion years
that finite distance in space that
finite extent
of the universe would only be finite
today
so how in the world can we possibly say
that the extent of space might be
infinite
if indeed it was finite at the big bang
and the answer is
we can't if the
extent of space is infinite today then
it would have been
infinite at the time of the big bang and
that
is an idea that perhaps we don't
emphasize as much as we should
but i suspect that the dominant view
among
professional cosmologists has been maybe
it's shifting over time
i haven't done a study a statistical
survey so i'm just
basing this on my sense of
people's view from conversations over
many years
but i think the dominant view is that
space is infinite
and what's being pointed out by ignacio
in this very good question
is that if it's infinite today then if
you go
halfway back toward the big bang halfway
back in time
then the universe will be smaller but
whatever fraction it is
a half a tenth a millionth if it's
infinite today
then a half a tenth or a millionth of
infinity
is still infinite so the universe would
be infinite
halfway back toward the big bang and if
you go three quarters of the way back to
the big bang it'll be some fraction
of the infinite infinite size today
which will still be
infinite in size and as you wind the
clock ever further back in time
you have a universe that's ever smaller
in the sense that objects in the
universe will get ever closer together
but the entire expanse of space
will continue to be infinite so the
image that we often have of a very
tiny speck at the big bang
expanding into the universe that we are
familiar with
is a little bit misleading that picture
is true for
all the finite distances that we
say are aware of that we can observe and
can measure
but if you're talking about the expanse
of reality
the spatial expanse of the universe in
its totality
then at the big bang that would have
been infinite
infinitely big it would have been
infinitely dense
and perhaps empty hot depending on which
cosmological theory
you subscribed to but it would be
infinitely long in the actual expanse of
space
itself so it is a somewhat different
image for the big bang than what we
often
have in mind but if it is infinite today
it will be infinite all the way back
okay what else do we have here um
at pratim rostoki asks hello professor
brian what is the flop transition was a
flop transition well
that's a a question that's uh close to
my heart
flop transitions uh i was part of the
discovery of that
now it's a long time ago it's just a
young man
with dark hair and more hair
this was 1992 at the institute for
advanced study in princeton
i think it was 1992. yeah and
i was spending a semester there and was
working with some of my good friends
david morrison paul aspinwall also ronan
plesser
was part of the conversations that in
pert important and
and uh important stages of that
discovery
and um we asked ourselves whether the
fabric of space well we all
we know from einstein it can stretch it
can twist it can compress
it can warp it can curve we asked
ourselves if you included quantum
effects
in the way that the general theory of
relativity does not but string theory at
least
allows you to begin to include these uh
post general relativity effects maybe
that's the best way of saying it
we asked ourselves whether space could
rip whether this fabric
you know excuse me this fabric itself
could puncture and
tear and of course we were studying it
mathematically as i
described in the first hour in the
conversation with gabriella gonzalez i
don't do anything experimental
unfortunately the closest i get to
experimental physics is like
measuring for a shoe rack
that i'm going to build this week in our
house
up here and that's as close as i get i'm
going to measure
the alcove and i'm going to use a saw to
cut it cut the wood that's about as
close as i get
but so we were doing a theoretical
investigation about whether the fabric
of space could puncture or tear
and we were doing this using the
mathematics of string theory
and within that mathematics we found the
possibility mathematically
that a certain operation that
mathematicians know about they call it
the flop
transition where you take a region of
space
and within that region of space you
collapse down a spherical portion
and you collapse it all the way down to
a point and then
you blow it up is the technical language
but it sort of sounds metaphorical you
kind of blow air
back into that sphere but you inflate it
in a different direction
in a different way than the direction
and the progression that you used when
you were shrinking it down
so you take a sphere you shrink it down
and then you re-expand it
and by doing the re-expansion in a
different way you actually
puncture the fabric and then you repair
it
but when you repair it the shape that
you wind up with is fundamentally
different
topologically different we call it from
the shape that you started with and we
asked ourselves
could that mathematical flop transition
i don't know why it's called a flop
maybe because
the sphere comes down and then you flop
it over when you
when you re-expand it maybe that's the
origin
of that terminology i don't actually
know the full origin but
that operation is called the flop
transition and we asked ourselves
whether
that might be realized by the physics of
string theory
and what we found after some some pretty
substantial pretty heavy calculations
some by hand some by computer we found
that string theory does
allow for the flop transition to take
place
which means you could imagine an actual
sequence of events described by string
theory
in which a spherical portion of space
itself
now not just an abstract geometrical
entity
but a spherical region of space itself
would shrink down
puncture and then re-inflate in a
flopped
direction fundamentally changing the
shape of space fundamentally
changing the topology of space and so we
were able to establish that those
operations
actually happen at the same time at the
institute for advanced study
we would we would meet every four
o'clock there's a very
genteel tea time this is einstein's old
stomping ground the institute for vance
studies so there's this
wonderful tradition that everybody from
all of the schools
at the institute for advanced study from
natural sciences you know from social
sciences from history
all get together in this big open area
which i suspect is no longer happening
now that i obviously think about the uh
the environment that we're in right now
but we'd all meet
and talk and ed whitton one of the
the greatest physicists of our age who
of course
is in some sense einstein's successor at
the institute for advanced study
we would tell him about our work so dave
morrison myself paul aspinwall who were
all at the institute at that time we
tell
edward whitney about our work and he got
really interested in this possibility
of the flop transition and he found his
own
way into the subject very different from
from
ours but his own way into the subject
and we came to the same conclusion at
the same time
that these uh topology changing
transitions could actually occur within
string theory
and so we we coordinated the publication
of our papers so that
each of us would feel that we had gotten
the uh the priority for the discovery
that we all deserved that we weren't
gonna
one-up anybody and it was a very uh very
uh a very kind of satisfying gratifying
really beautiful
period of time for me to be part of a
discovery
of of significance but one that was
being done in
a very cordial and very information
sharing a very open manner so that's
kind of how you uh
hope these things would would actually
work so
that's what the flop transition was all
about
uh mukherjee asked sir is consciousness
a property of particles or is it
something else and
upal i hope again i'm pronouncing your
name correctly i apologize
uh the answer to your question is i
don't know
nobody does so it's one of the big big
unanswered questions of not just modern
science but of
of modernity right modernity right i
mean this is one of the big questions
that we
ask ourselves is the light that's on
is the movie that's playing inside of
our head is the voice that we hear
chattering away between our ears
is that conscious experience of sight
and sound
and smell and taste and internal
abstract reflection
is that due to the motion of particles
inside of our brain
and nothing else or is there something
else and now certainly the motion of
particles does
affect our conscious awareness right
anybody who's
had some kind of uh issue with their
brain
or anybody who has injected foreign
substances
into their brains knows that
those new particle motions
affect the conscious experience that you
have that's unassailable
right that's that's manifestly the case
but the question is is it just the
particles
or is there something else what might
the something else be well
some people say there's a consciousness
field out there
like the electromagnetic field or like
the gravitational field that we're
talking about in the first hour
with gabriella gonzalez and that our
brain somehow
tap into that external consciousness
field
is it possible yeah it's possible i
don't see any evidence for it but i
don't dismiss it
out of hand as being nonsense
i don't think it's true but i have an
open mind
could it instead be that there is no
consciousness field per se
it's just the particles inside of our
head but maybe almost as uppal
suggested maybe the property of
consciousness
is somehow embedded into the particles
themselves
particles somehow are imprinted with
have embedded within them the properties
of
of mass of spin of electric
charge could there be another kind of
quality a consciousness charge
that's also embedded within particles
and when many of these particles come
together their individual
consciousness charges can coalesce to
yield consciousness as we experience it
is that possible yeah
definitely possible again i consider it
a far
out idea a beautiful spectacular idea
but one that i don't see any evidence
for which doesn't mean it's not
true and so my my view is somewhat more
conservative or depending on your
perspective
some people call it more outlandish but
my
conservative view is that all you need
is the known particles
with the known qualities and all you
need is those particles to come together
into the right organized pattern and to
carry out the right organized
motions you know various electromagnetic
charged particles moving along various
quantum mechanical trajectories i think
that's all you need
to yield consciousness as we know it
so i am a great fan of these more exotic
proposals
i would be tickled silly if one day
we learned that there is a consciousness
field i would
dance for joy if one day we could prove
that electrons have another quality
called proto-consciousness
that's the precursor to consciousness as
we experience it
if any of that were ever to happen
oh my god invoking now even another
explanation
i mean holy cow or whatever
excited word you use for things that
are wondrous that would be
fantastic to learn that consciousness is
inside of particles or out there in a
field
i don't think it's going to happen i
think that we're going to
come to the conclusion incrementally i
don't think it's going to be a big
breakthrough one day
but step by step we will see that every
quality of consciousness
including the inner experience of it
that's the big controversy
but i even think that the inner
experience of conscious awareness we
will one day be able to
explain using the language of physics
particles and laws or whatever language
supersedes
particles laws and fields in the future
so
that that's where i come down on that
story but uh it's a it's a big and
important
open question that um we just have to uh
wait and see where
where it all comes out so kev's
creations
on the youtube chat says god would be
the best
explanation for consciousness and you
may be surprised kev's creations or
everybody else who's uh with us at the
moment
i i i kind of agree with that in a way i
don't know about best per se but it
would be a spectacular explanation
if god is the explanation for
consciousness i don't resist that idea
again i don't see any evidence for it i
don't see any evidence for god doesn't
mean that
god is not real as i've discussed in
these
forums earlier i view religion as a
vital quality
in the human progression and
i view it as a very beautiful
way of trying to make sense of our place
in
the grand cosmic schema i don't see god
as an explanation for things like the
electrons magnetic moment
or einstein's field equations that we
spoke about in the last hour
that isn't i think where
the invocation of god
provides us any particular insight but
any
place where it can provide us insight i
welcome
that insight and if one day it gives us
insight into consciousness
wow great amazing
again i don't think that's where things
will go
but if they do go in that direction it's
not something that i find
distasteful it's not something that i
find giving up
if you can really establish and that's
the big question how do you establish
that the inclusion of god in
our musings and in our descriptions of
consciousness
adds real illumination deeply satisfying
and gratifying and even predictive
illumination
great that would be that would be
fantastic
again i don't think that's where it's
going but i allow for that
possibility rob b asks is there a
distance limit for cause and effect
can a butterfly on another planet have
an effect on earth no there's no
distance limit
that we know of we recognize that there
is a limit on the speed of propagation
of an influence i do something here
i clap my hands it took some
fraction of a second for the oscillating
air molecules to bounce into my
microphone
which then took some time to send an
electric
signal along the cables that are plugged
into my computer
which then travel and yield a cascade of
other
influences that travel through other
wires and
other means of communication through the
internet
ultimately reaching your speaker on your
computer
which then vibrates in a manner that
reflects
what i just did and then that vibration
travels
through the air and causes your eardrum
to vibrate
so that cascade of influence travels
from me
up here in upstate new york to wherever
you are
around the world and there's a time
delay for that to happen
but there's no distance limit it's just
a speed limit and that speed limit is
the speed of light
so no signal can communicate
information from one location to another
at a speed greater than the speed of
light
but no there's no distance limitation so
yeah if there is another planet that has
a butterfly
on it the you know proverbial
disturbance on planet earth from a
butterfly flapping its wings in
early times and that causing a domino
effect
little tiny domino effects that can
influence how the world is subsequently
that can happen from an influence on a
distant planet
even right now you know if i snap my
fingers or let me even just say i
rapidly move my arms i am creating a
gravitational
disturbance gravitational disturbance
and that disturbance is tiny
but it ripples out there in space
and there's no distance limit in fact
you know the
disturbance that gabriella gonzalez
spoke about in the first hour
we didn't talk about it i guess but
the two black holes that collided giving
rise to the signal on september 14th at
five o'clock in the morning those two
black holes
were more than a billion light years
away
a billion light years right a light year
i don't know what units you like to use
but
it's something like you know six
trillion miles if you like miles but
kilometers will hardly be different so
call it whatever four trillion
kilometers or
bigger i said i said that backwards
right to be greater than
than 6 trillion but whatever it's
trillions of kilometers
in a single light year you're talking
about more than a billion light years
and that influence which happened more
than a billion years ago
when those two black holes collided more
than a billion years ago
more than a billion light years away
that ripple in the fabric of space
just continued to travel outward until
on september 14th at five o'clock in the
morning
it reached us in louisiana
and in washington state and caused the
two ligo detectors to shake
so there you have it a beautiful example
of
there being no distant no distance
limit on how far away something can be
and have uh some influence on us
here now i just noticed somewhere in
capital letters in the chat
somebody in capital letters wrote you
are wrong
but they didn't tell me what i was wrong
about
[Music]
and i can't actually even find it any
longer so if whoever thinks that i'm
i'm wrong with such vigor
and vehemence i'm i'm open to being told
where i'm wrong
but you got to give me more than just
you are wrong
not much i uh not much that i can do
with that
at all okay what else do we have here
that we could have some fun with i'm
gonna go to the other
twitter feed let me see if there any
things coming in from there that catch
my
eye i don't seem to have the twitter
feed at all okay
so if you're asking questions on on
twitter unfortunately they're not coming
through to me so
apologies let me just go back to the uh
to the youtube
thread here um
um
so if gravity and light have the same
speed this is another question for
margin i like these this line
some do the unusual thing to give origin
maybe it's not the same person though i
think the last name may be different
if gravity and light have the same speed
can we say that light and gravity are
made
of something which have a common
property and
i i don't know i don't think so right
when we talk about light
as the electromagnetic field we're
talking about
it in a quantum language we introduce a
notion of
photons and we're talking about gravity
we talk about
the fabric of space-time we talk about
ripples in the fabric of space-time and
there if we inject quantum mechanics
we are talking about gravitons and
fundamentally
we really do think about light and
gravity
photons and gravitons it's just being
different i mean there may be a unified
theory
maybe it's string theory in which they
are brought together
into a single rubric maybe vibrating
strings
is the right language to talk about
there
but fundamentally just because photons
and gravitons travel at the same speed
we would not say they're made of the
same stuff but then you could say
like why the same speed i started tried
to give some insight into that earlier
but
but maybe a way of saying it would be
the speed
of light and the speed of gravity
are indicative they are
reflecting a more fundamental quality
of reality that transcends light
and it transcends gravity and the
feature that i'm talking about
sorry about that phone ringing and i
forgot to shut it off you know
out of i'm out of practice hey if
someone's listening for this at the main
house can you pick up the phone so i
don't have to have that irritating ring
happen great thank you so much picked it
up
so the point i was making is that the
more fundamental quality that the speed
of light
and the speed of gravity tap into is
causality
causality is the more fundamental
quality
of reality that each of these things
reflect and what does causality mean we
know what it means
it means that a an event
and b another event a can only
affect b if there's enough time for a
signal from event a
to reach event b before
event b actually happens right again you
know
just now i caused your ears to hear
my finger snapping and that means that
the event of you hearing my finger
snapping and my finger snapping
they have to stand in a very particular
relationship which means
there has to be enough time between my
finger snapping
and your ear hearing my finger snapping
there must be enough time for the signal
to travel from here
to wherever you are now on earth that's
not much of a constraint
light can go around the earth seven
times in a single second so
signals travel really quickly on the
scales that
we are talking about but fundamentally
that's what the speed of light is
it is something that is deeply
reflective of
causality that event a can affect
event b only if they stand in a very
particular causal relationship
and that then gives us a different way
of thinking about the speed of light the
speed of gravity speed of light and
speed of gravity are both in some sense
reflecting or ensuring or protecting
causality and causality transcends light
it transcends gravity it transcends the
signal
by which an influence is transmitted
from here to there
so the universe basically says that
causality demands that there is a limit
to how fast signals can propagate and
light
reaches that limit and gravity reaches
that limit
and that limit in conventional units is
671
million miles an hour or whatever units
you like
300 million meters per second and
light reaches that limit in its speed
and gravity reaches
that causal limit and its beat and
that's why fundamentally
light and gravity have the same speed
they are maxing out the speed if you
will
of causality so they're reflecting the
causal nature
of events in the world
and therefore their speeds
are the same not because they are deeply
related although they may be
their speeds are related because they
are both
reflecting causality the nature of
causality in the world
okay um
martin topinka what is the easiest
explanation for why gravitational waves
start with a quadrupole radiation
as opposed to the monopole or the dipole
in the language that we physicists would
use and um
you know uh i don't know that i have a
really good intuitive
explanation for that so what martin is
pointing out is if you have a
a completely spherical motion
of matter that is spherically symmetric
then even though you've got matter
moving it won't generate
a gravitational wave you need a more
messy
motion that doesn't
respect that spherical symmetry
in order for gravitational radiation now
this emerges right from einstein's
theory you know one way of saying it i
don't know if this is going to
help at all but in general relativity
the degree of freedom that's really
fundamental
is the distance between two locations
because after all what does a
gravitational wave do
it changes that distance now how do you
measure distance what's the mathematical
gadget that you use well it's something
called the metric
the metric tensor you know about this
metric from the pythagorean theorem
right if i have two points on the
cartesian
plane that are separated by delta x and
delta y
how do you get the distance from one
point to another how do you get the
distance of that hypotenuse well it's
delta x squared
plus delta y squared that gives you
delta z
squared or delta c squared if it's
usually
delta a squared delta b squared delta c
squared
so so you see that there's a way of
measuring distances that makes use of
the squares of the separations more
generally it's a quadratic form
it's an entity that has in a delta x
delta y
even cross terms like delta x delta y
can show up in the most
general version of this quadratic form
and because it's a quadratic form that
it involves squares
in the pythagorean theorem that means
that the metric tensor has
two indices not one index we usually
write it as g
mu nu times delta x mu
delta x nu in the more general way of
framing things if you let me speak math
speak for a moment
and the fact that the metric tensor has
two indices
not one is what takes us to the
quadrupole
as opposed to say the dipole or even the
monopole
and that mathematically is where it
comes out in einstein's general theory
of relativity i i know that's not
particularly intuitive
i gotta think of a better intuitive
explanation but mathematically
that's the answer to your question
all right what else do we have here what
time is it oh it's uh
it's 104. we've been going about two
hours um
let me just uh answer a few more
questions
and then we'll uh
try to uh try to wrap that up eric w
says i like brian's hair today
well thank you eric my wife
tracy actually snipped off a few of the
ends of my
hair the other day my first haircut in
six months
so if you like how it looks
then we have tracy day to thank for that
okay back to physics spin foams asked
sir what is quantum romanian geometry in
the mathematical context of strength
well a lot of technical
questions at the moment let me just take
a sip of my
my mud water here
uh coconut tea with soy oat milk today
so we all know or at least we've heard
if you don't know in detail
that what einstein did in classical
general relativity
is borrow the whole mathematical
structure of
romanian geometry developed by bernard
riemann
1800s who worked
under gauss
who also made use of
the ideas of other mathematicians like
lobochevsky
and others and so there is this body
of classical geometry by which i mean
the ordinary geometry that you learn
about in school but augmented
to include curved surfaces right so
standard euclidean geometry that we all
study
at least in america we typically study
in the 9th or 10th grade
it really focuses upon shapes that are
drawn on a flat surface
or 3d shapes but again embedded in a
flat
euclidean environment einstein
and his physical incorporation of these
ideas into the general theory of
relativity
generalizes this to make use of the
romanian geometry of curved
surfaces and curved shapes
if you now include quantum effects
you're in the realm of quantum romanian
geometry
or quantum gravity so the answer to your
question really is that quantum gravity
can be thought of as the
mathematical structure that injects
quantum mechanics
into the classical geometrical structure
of general relativity which is romanian
geometry
so what is quantum gravity in some sense
it's quantum
romanian geometry now string theory
is one approach to quantum romanian
geometry
and in answer to an earlier question
about flop transitions
flop transitions i've already noted
one weird quality of quantum romanian
geometry that is not manifest that does
not
exist really in classical romanian
geometry
which is that there's a smooth operation
that allows you to tear the fabric of
space
that was that flop transition that i
that i mentioned
earlier where you take one shape of
space
squeeze down a sphere puncture the space
then re-inflate that sphere in kind of
an orthogonal or flopped
direction and that new smooth
geometry that emerges from that process
has a fundamentally different shape
fundamentally different topology
that would not happen in classical
romanian geometry
there'd be a singularity in the process
but in quantum romanian geometry there's
no singularity
it's a smooth physical process but look
string theory is just one approach
to quantum gravity and therefore it's
just one approach to quantum remaining
geometry there are other approaches
and we don't know which is right and so
we'll have to wait
for future insights to tell us which of
any of those is right but that
is what quantum remaining geometry is
and that gives you some sense of the
string theoretic approach
to this kind of geometry
a local titans asked do gravitons in
gravity act just the same as photons and
electromagnetism the anger is totally
not
local titans i mean we often
analogize between say
the photon is to the electromagnetic
field
as the graviton is to the gravitational
field
so that's a nice a nice analogy
that gives you a sense of what a
graviton is
but the detailed mathematical
description about how a graviton behaves
how it interacts how it moves the kinds
of processes that it can be involved
with
that mathematics is completely different
from the mathematics that governs
similar questions for the photon for the
photon it's maxwell's equations or
more precisely the quantum mechanical
version
of maxwell's equations which is known as
quantum electrodynamics
for the graviton it's quantum gravity
and again there are approaches still
tentative for what quantum gravity is
and string theory is one of those
possibilities but
within string theory the quantum
mechanical property of gravitons they're
very different
from the quantum mechanical property of
photons
for instance their spin is different
the photon has quantum mechanical spin
of one
in the appropriate units that we use the
quantum mechanical spin
of a graviton is spin two double
and that relates right back to my
earlier remark about
the metric being a quadratic form it has
two indices
these the analogous degree of freedom
for the photon
is the electromagnetic potential or the
u1
gauge connection if you want to use
technical language
often written down as a mu that is one
index
that one index is indicative of the
photon having spin one
whereas the two indices g mu nu on the
metric tensor are indicative of the
photon having spin
two so the answer is no their properties
are
absolutely not the same
um mr space is space distance measured
in zoom
in if yes what is the start and end
point
zoom in i mean i i got that has nothing
to do with how we're communicating
zoom or youtube i i tauren i don't
understand the question mr space maybe
you can reframe it
sorry i don't know what to say in that
um
what else we have here
time walker is there any upper or lower
limit to the wavelength or frequency of
light
if you're dealing with classical
electromagnetic theory and you're
ignoring gravity
then the answer is no you can have a
wavelength of
any size that you like the math is
agnostic to the particular wavelength or
the
particular frequency if you're doing
quantum mechanics
and you're including gravity in your
story as well
then the situation is somewhat different
because
we know that the energy of a photon
is directly proportional to its
frequency e equals h nu
nu is the frequency and
if the energy of a photon exceeds
a certain value like that of the uh the
planck
mass then you have to start worrying
about does that photon
turn into a black hole because
its energy is so large
and its its wavelength so
short that it
exceeds the bounds allowed
for an object to resist gravitational
collapse
so the formation of black holes comes
into the story
and makes it a far more complicated
situation
than in the case of classical
electromagnetic theory in the absence
of gravity for which the answer to your
question would be yes
taken to these other effects the answer
would be no
um do you think a theory must be true if
it seems elegant
karam absolutely not absolutely not
so the ultimate arbiter of what's right
what's wrong is observation it's
experiment there's no substitute for
that
so you know my first book was called the
elegant universe
and within that book i try to make the
case
that string theory is a very elegant
theory
that it is a very elegant way of
combining
the general theory of relativity and
quantum mechanics but nowhere in that
book
and nowhere in the many many
conversations since that book was
published back in 1999
have i ever made the argument that
because the theory is elegant it is true
i never say that i say because it's
elegant
it inspires us because it's elegant it
may
give us additional motivation to
consider it and to examine it i mean if
you come to me
with a very inelegant very clumsy
very clue-g version of a theory i'll
look at it and i'm
repelled by the mathematics and i don't
want to study it
it may be true but i don't feel
compelled to study it because
my aesthetic sensibility is violated
by the ugly theory that you've presented
me with yes i will say that but i would
never say
that the beauty of a theory is the
ultimate arbiter of whether it's right
or wrong
and that's why i'm the first to say that
i don't know if string theory is right
i'm the first to say that i'm highly
skeptical
about string theory i'm impressed by the
beauty
i'm impressed by the elegance of the
mathematical formulation
i'm impressed by the achievements
that string theory has already made
in understanding things like black holes
in the nature of space-time and things
of that sort
but all that is circumstantial the only
thing that would truly convince me of
the veracity
of string theory is some kind of
observation or experiment that we simply
could not explain in any other way
or better still if it was a prediction
that came out
of the analysis of the mathematics of
string theory
and then we go and look for it and we
confirm it that's the dream that's the
goal we're not there yet
we are not there yet with string theory
but
to answer the question beauty elegance
will never be
enough never be enough
sounds like a lyric from the greatest
showman
it'll never be enough for me never never
somebody out there sing it for us i'm
not gonna
embarrass myself my daughter was here
i'd ask her to sing it
okay what else do we have here
geraldine morrow asked dr green does
quantum mechanics allow
free will and i would say sure it allows
free will because there are aspects of
quantum mechanics that we don't yet
fully understand the quantum measurement
problem
is still an unresolved issue as far as i
am concerned
and yeah so it's possible that one day
when we fill in these final
details of quantum mechanics somewhere
within those details we will see ah-ha
there is free will and the quantum
mechanical equations properly and
completely formulated
do i think that's going to happen i do
not
my suspicion and that's all that it is
my suspicion is that the final details
of quantum mechanics when fully
understood
will not change the current
view that i hold and many others too
about free will which is that it's
not real in the traditional formulation
again the argument is simply that you
and i are made of collections of
particles those particles
are governed by laws of physics whatever
those laws may be
quantum mechanical certainly as far as
we can tell
but provisional in our current
understanding
and because you are made of particles
and your brain is made of particles and
because every decision you make and
every thought you have
and every sensation that you acquire
amounts to your particle configuration
shifting from one configuration
to another and those configuration
shifts are fully governed as far as we
can tell by mathematical law
there's no opportunity for a you to
intercede
and somehow change the course of the law
progression of the particle
configuration taking place in your brain
what would it mean for you to have free
will you'd have to be able to get in on
the action
intercede and somehow
violate the
physical laws that ordinarily hold
sway and i don't see any opportunity for
you to do that
i don't see any opportunity for you to
get in on the action in that way
i don't see any opportunity for you to
exert
free will in the usual sense of
transcending
outside influence in this case the
outside influence being the fundamental
laws of physics
but again as i'm said at the outset if
the laws are such
that they do allow for that in a way
that we don't currently understand
because the laws are provisional
sure possible but again just to put that
in context if you were to ask me is it
possible that the moon is made of blue
cheese or mozzarella cheese or swiss
cheese
i say yeah it's possible you know
maybe underneath the surface it's swiss
cheese
i don't think so but you know we've not
dug it down 10 miles
and show that we haven't encountered
swiss cheese or
you know we know the density of the moon
so
i have to be swiss cheese of the right
density and all that sort of jazz but
you get the point
there are many things that could be true
that i would nod my head and say yeah it
could be true
but it's pretty far-fetched and i
consider the moon being swiss cheese to
be one of them
and i consider quantum mechanics giving
rise to free will to be
another one of those unlikely but
possible
ways in which things will advance
ayanna enache is it possible that the
human brain may
may be a quantum computer well in a
sense it is i think the brain does
undertake
computations and i do think that those
computations are fully governed by
quantum physics
so there is a manifest way in which the
brain already
is a quantum computer but i know what
you mean you're talking about
the kinds of computers that were now on
the road
and route to building in the laboratory
could those more
correctly capture the kinds of processes
in the brain sure it's possible
it could be that the metaphor for brain
processes will change over time from
the classical computational metaphor
that we use
often the brains like a computer maybe
as we understand
quantum computation and as we build
quantum computers
maybe that metaphor will change and
we'll say oh yeah the brain is much more
like a quantum computer
could well could well be going forward i
just don't know
all right let's see uh sanjay powwar
says wait for a minute i am writing okay
i'm waiting sanjay
waiting waiting i don't see anything yet
from you so i'm going to move on to
somebody else
saad raza tell us how to learn math
there's really only one way to learn
math and that's by practice
you know you can watch videos and get
the basic idea
but in any math course i've ever taken
it wasn't until i began to do
calculations with the math
that i understood what's going on in
fact i had a very interesting experience
as a graduate student
many years ago i was taking an advanced
mathematics class at harvard
with a great math teacher cannot
remember his name i do remember he came
to class with two big dogs
a bit unusual but but a great math
teacher
and we were learning things about
algebraic geometry
we're learning things about abstract
things
about various kinds of spaces and
you know vector bundles and principle
bundles and all this stuff
and i remember i was using that math i
was learning it
to sort of reaffirm what i already knew
from my physics research and string
theory so anyway i'm taking this class
and i'm i'm like lining up
the things that he's teaching us with
the kinds of calculations that i was
already doing in string theory so one
day after class i go to this professor
with i guess i was a graduate graduate i
go to this professor with one of my
calculations
and i just wanted to ask him some
questions about the calculation and he
turned to me and said he said look
i think you know these calculations
better than i do he said look i'm
teaching
these ideas in abstract he said but i
rarely if ever do any calculations
with this mathematics so there was a
weird
way in which i knew the math better in
some way than he did
because i was actually using it to get
numbers
to calculate things whereas he was just
way up in the clouds
teaching it in a fully abstract way
so it was an enlightening moment for me
when i realized that doing calculations
finding examples of the abstract
mathematical concepts is
absolutely essential at any level that
you're learning
to have the the deepest understanding of
what's going on so
saad raza that's my advice for
how to go about learning mathematics
um akshat
shukla is math the language to write the
universe
uh certainly there are people who
thought that
i mean you know plato famously
over the entrance to one of the
places where students would gather he
said something like you know if you
don't speak the language of math or
geometry there's no place for you here
because that's like where the deepest
truths were galileo
thought that the language of math was
written in the language of geometry
so many people have said that math is a
language for writing the universe
i i don't know i don't know that that's
true
i've lived my life as if it is true
because i've lived my life spending a
long time learning the
the language of mathematics and applying
that language to try to understand
things about the world
better and math
unassailably undoubtedly
is a powerful tool for making
things about the world clearer but
i've said this before is it possible
that one day we'll have a conversation
with alien life forms and those life
forms will say to us
no it's not math they'll say to us hey
we tried that for the first 10
000 years of our civilization
and yeah we came upon something
analogous to your
general relativity we came upon
something analogous to your quantum
field theory
or they may say we came up on this other
thing that you guys never figured out
never discovered but it might all be
mathematical but then they'll say
at some point we realized that math was
a dead end
we realized that math could take you
part way along the
road to reality but only part way
and we realize that this other approach
non-mathematical in its basic structure
is really how you grasp reality
i don't know i've said before i don't
know what that other approach would be
in fact i can't even imagine what it
would be
and not somehow secretly be mathematics
disguised
in a different vocabulary a different
formulation
but if math is just sort of pattern
recognition
encapsulated in a predictive way
it's hard to imagine what description of
the universe doesn't fit that
rubric and therefore wouldn't be math
and disguise but i don't know
i certainly do allow for the possibility
that um that math is not to be on
end-all
that it's just a stepping stone to a
deeper understanding i don't know if you
guys have any ideas
what might supersede mathematics in
describing
reality be interested to hear whatever
possibilities come to mind
but akshat shukla i don't know
that math is the language to write the
universe could be
also could not be um sam o'neill says
could it be possible that we need a new
math like newton invented calculus to
understand the universe and
sam certainly that's the case and
earlier i don't know if you were with us
somebody asked about
quantum ramanian geometry
which is a new mathematical structure
that did not come out of
mathematical research it came out of
physics research
so those physicists like me who spend
time
thinking about quantum gravity have been
led
to develop a new mathematical structure
that incorporates quantum mechanics
into the old gravitational mathematics
which was romanian geometry developed in
the 1800s
so that classical romanian geometry from
the 1800s
updated with the insights from physics
quantum mechanics in particular
yields exactly what sam is suggesting a
new math
that new math is quantum remaining in
geometry that has things like i
described before
topology changing transitions
and other qualities as well so
in fact there was a there was a
class held at the institute for advanced
study which i brought up earlier when
talking about flop transitions
reinstein was for for many decades
there was a class held i don't know 10
years ago maybe longer
time flies and it was a class for the
world's greatest mathematicians
to learn about the new math
emerging from string theory and other
cutting edge approaches to physics so
it was kind of the striking thing where
you had a tutorial
for some of the greatest mathematicians
in the world so that they
could learn about the new mathematical
ideas emerging from physics
so yeah sam this happens it happens all
the time
and it happens in a very uh
interesting and productive ways
[Music]
safiq raza sir you really look like old
century great scientists like newton and
galileo
do i i don't know if that's a compliment
or an insult or just an
observation i'll just i'll take it as a
compliment although
the pictures of newton with the long
frilly curly blonde hair
i don't know maybe i guess i got all
these curls happening at the moment
but actually i'll tell you something my
student pontus alquest great student of
mine one of the best students i've had
now works for google i believe or
alphabet or whatever it's called
he sent me an email yesterday
i would try to find it but there's a
psychology project
i don't know if you've ever looked at
this where for every
researcher in math maybe physics too you
can figure out
from the genealogy project who their
advisor was
and who the advisor of their advisor was
and you can like
follow this trail it's like a family
tree
but not for birth relations
not for genetic relations but rather for
who is your advisor advise advisorial
relationship if i can use that language
so he told me
and if i i can't remember how many but
he he found out from the math genealogy
project that i
and hence he since he's my student that
i am the great
great great great great great great
great great great great great great
great great i think it was 15.
great grand advisee of isaac newton
that's funny right so you got isaac
newton and he has some advisor who has
another
person that's their advisor and you
follow it all down the family tree
and you get presumably to graham ross at
oxford
who is my graduate advisor great advisor
in particle physics i was doing my
dissertation in the early days of string
theory graham ross with my advisor
and then then comes me so that that that
family tree from adviser to student goes
all the way back
to isaac newton and pontus my student
gets one more grand in that story
because he's one step further down the
train
so yeah so maybe maybe somehow
the influence of isaac newton however
diluted
follows through that that family tree
that's uh that's what you hope
all right anyway what do we have here um
taj thomas asked brian we now have
scientific evidence of consciousness
existing outside of the body you're
going the wrong way
wrong wrong way um i'd love to see that
evidence
charge thomas i've looked at times
as carefully as the literature allowed
to see the claims that consciousness
exists outside the body
i've never seen anything convincing so
if you have something convincing
i would love to see it because look as i
said i'm not dogmatic about these things
if there truly is evidence that
consciousness is beyond
the physical i'd love to see it
but every supposed piece of evidence of
that sort every purported
piece of evidence that people point
toward
to establish that consciousness
supersedes the physical
is beyond the physical every piece that
i've looked at
either was not convincing or wasn't
doing
the work that the interpretation
suggested that it was doing
it may have suggested something
interesting about consciousness
[Music]
but i've never seen anything that's
proven
established that consciousness exists
beyond the body
so i'd love to see it i
i don't know i don't know what that
would be like
uh moniel corania how does
thermodynamics explain the universe
that's a big
question mo neil and
that's one of the rare times that i'm
actually going to refer to a book
i'm going to ask you to look at until
the end of time get it from your local
library not trying to make any sales
here i think that's all gross when
people do that
you know how people have these
interviews and they say well you know in
my book
you know until the end of time you know
or
you know it's funny you should ask that
question because in my book until the
end of time i hate it when people do
that
it makes my skin crawl so i'm not doing
that but what i am doing is say
look at the book until the end of time
in a library or get a bootload copy
online
they exist and that book is all about
entropy helps explain the origin
development the evolution of the
universe and how speaking of which the
word evolution
is a counterpart to entropy that allows
us to understand how interesting
structures can emerge
in an environment heading toward
ever-greater disorder as demanded by the
second law of thermodynamics so
that's my best statement that's my best
answer
on the role of thermodynamics in
explaining the universe
so check that out read it if you have
questions come back when we have another
one of these meetings and i would be
more than happy to address any questions
that come up guy richard says yes you
are lol i guess you are
promoting your book i guess i am but i'm
seriously saying
get it from a library or search online
for
an illegal bootleg pdf copy
i don't care about where you get it it's
just it's the best answer i can provide
okay what else do we have um uh rbs do
you think
time travel to the past is possible by
using
a machine yeah referring to the papers
of ronald mallett yeah so
as i've said many times before i don't
think time travel to the past is
is likely to ever happen
and um the reason for that is manifold
there's a deep tension between time
travel to the past and our understanding
about physics and causality
it doesn't mean it's impossible for time
travel to the past to happen it's just
very difficult to see how it fits in
with our understanding of things that's
not an
argument obviously but um
and there are proposed ways and there
are people who have thought deeply about
this kip thorne
joe polczynski delay joel pochinski
great physicist
uh and and uh the papers that you refer
to
they're interesting definitely
interesting papers
but i would say most people believe that
when we understand
physics to a greater level
of precision than we do today we
understand some things quite well
but we understand to a greater degree of
precision we're going to find
that time travel to the past is ruled
out again no argument
that fully closes the door on try and
travel to the past
so it may happen but uh i just uh
i just don't think uh i just don't think
it's possible
so guy richardson comes back and says i
love you man well thank you
i appreciate that i appreciate that
somebody else wrote
you look as tired as hell i know where
that is do i
i don't actually feel that tired i have
been talking now for two hours and 40
minutes
so i may not have the same zip
that i might ordinarily and i will be
wrapping this up
there satya satya how
ladder you look tired as well thank you
satya i'm
always appreciative of when people say
how tired i look
you know it's always a wonderful moment
in a public
setting so thank you thank you so much
for uh for bringing that to everybody's
attention but actually i feel okay
so i'm gonna answer a few more few more
questions
um karam salangi is the idea of living
in a simulation
unfalsifiable i i
do think it's unfalsifiable for the
simple reason that
if the simulator can always go
into the record of your memories
and rewind that record and undo
them if they for instance came to an
argument that established that the
simulation
was real or not but have to be real
if that can if that memory and thought
process can always
be erased within the simulation i don't
see any obstacle to that
then that's a version of the simulation
hypothesis
in which any individual within that
simulation who figures out that they are
in a simulation the moment they figure
that out that memory will be wiped away
if so facto it seems that that
simulation that version of the
simulation hypothesis is unfalsifiable
uh hassan ali do you think the neurolink
will succeed
uh you know i think we're in
the infancy of understanding the mind
i think we are at the very beginning
of sorting out the physical
physiological the physiochemical
the physical and biological
qualities that allow the mind to exist
that
any attempt at this early stage
to really tap into that in a manner as
suggested by
things like the neural link i think it's
extremely unlikely to work
now but let's take time scales out of
the question and just talk about will
these kinds of things work
ever and if we survive if we don't
annihilate ourselves
then yeah i think that's the kind of
mind machine interface that's the kind
of
mind reality interface that i do think
will be in our future
now that can be good or can be bad
depending on how
such technology is used i'm an optimist
and i like to think that things will be
used in a good way so i find it deeply
exciting
that our ability to reach inside the
mind
will have such sophistication
in the future in fact i imagine that it
would be so sophisticated
that many of the issues that now
befuddle us
about the nature of mind i believe that
they will go away
once you're able to reach inside the
mind and erase the boundary between the
outer world and the inner world perhaps
once the outer world and the inner world
become
become so
deeply connected that the move from one
to other is smooth and continuous
the idea of the inner world being
radically distinct
from the outer world will go away
and just as we deeply understand the
outer world in the language of physics
and particles and laws and rules
i believe that that will be the same
kind of description
that we will give for the inner world
and at that point the mysteries of
consciousness
the mysteries of inner awareness that's
when i think that they will evaporate
when the border between outer world and
inner world
is breached you know it's like it's like
you know you've got the the the northern
wall
in game of thrones and it's breached and
the worlds now
become interconnected that's the kind of
interconnection i imagine
will one day happen okay
um any i am asks any insights in what
makes space and time the constituents
and you know we're going to have a
conversation
in the not too distant future about
the work in relating quantum
entanglement
to the space-time fabric and i say
that's the most advanced
language that we have that the threads
stitching space-time may themselves be
the threads of quantum entanglement
if that doesn't mean anything to you
don't worry we're going to come back to
it in a nice conversation in the next
few weeks so look out for that
world science festival discussion with
uh
leaders in this charge mark vomronsdoc
lenny suskind others as well
where we'll start with the very basic
ideas of quantum entanglement move
through
some of the ideas of wormholes and then
come to the union of these ideas
as suggested by recent work in string
theory so
so that's my best answer and i'm
deferring it somewhat because we'll have
a full programmatic coming forward
but that's about the best thing that we
can say the most
detailed thing that we can say about the
constituents the possible constituents
of space and time
hamanchu asks why are the extra
dimensions curled up and small is there
any way to visualize them intuitively
um there are ways to invisalize them
into
they don't have to be incredibly small
in fact i don't even know if
now we'll test the uh the
the the swiftness of our world science
festival team i don't know if josh can
actually find the video
where we penetrate into the fabric of
space
and we see the extra dimensions as
tiny and curled up shapes the the
analogy we often use
starts with a garden hose and ants
walking upon it i don't know if we can
find that kind of visual
if we do i'll show that to you but but
the answer to question is the extra
dimensions don't have to be small they
could be big
we often describe them as small that's
one way of making them invisible they're
just so small that we don't see them
but uh they could be big
and it's just that light can't penetrate
through them
and they're invisible because we don't
have access to them because the forces
by which we access the outer world
don't penetrate into those extra
dimensions that is a possibility too
so if we're able to find that that kind
of fun
video um uh just run it at any moment
and i'll uh
and i'll just uh break into a
description
of it because it's kind of fun to have a
an actual visualization
of these curled up extra dimensions
within
the ordinary environment that we all
exist within but uh it's hard to give a
visualization
without visuals so if that happens to uh
come up as i'm talking i will break in
and
uh and explain it to you it's kind of
fun to see
um but i'm going to move on for now josh
paul what are my thoughts about
boltzmann brains boston brains this
possibility that the far future
random particle motions out there in
space might sort of come together
and just random particles reproduce a
brain
floating out there in the void and it's
a beautiful and strange idea
because let's say my brain right now if
my brain is just a
particular configuration of particles an
arrangement of electrons and protons and
neutrons and so forth
if i was somehow able to have that
particle configuration
reproduced out there in space that brain
would think it's me
because if you don't agree that there is
anything beyond consciousness
which i that's my suspicion if you do
agree that particles and laws is all
that there is
once you reproduce the particle
arrangement you're done you've
reproduced the conscious experience
so a boltzmann brain is a possibility of
a brain
randomly coalescing from random particle
emotions out there in space
could it happen yes it's possible most
of us view boltzmann brains as a kind of
diagnostic tool where
if our theories allow them to form or at
least form too easily then we don't
trust our theories
because look if my brain could form out
there in the void
then my brain would have all the
memories that i currently hold in this
brain
but that brain couldn't really trust
those memories because
those memories weren't of things that
actually happened
that brain is a memory of general
relativity learning in
school but that brain never had that
experience
that's just a figment of that brain's
memory
imprinted by the particular arrangement
of particles out there in the void
which is just to say that you become
skeptical of
everything if the possibility that you
are a boltzmann brain
is brought into the story so again
like many of my colleagues i view
baltimore brains as a diagnostic tool
where we say if our theory allows for
them
too easily to form then we don't trust
our own theory
then that's often how people look at
these things
i i don't really sit around and worry
that i actually am a boltzmann brain
that
isn't the attitude that i take in
response to the possibility
okay patrice young says i am here i'm
glad you are
patrice i'm not sure if i'm supposed to
conclude anything by your presence
if i am to include more details but
welcome patrice um
rutra kunha asks what's your strategy
to learn really complicated ideas when
you're stuck
that's a good question not often asked
that what is my strategy
well my strategy often is to come up
with examples
so if i'm stuck i'm usually stuck
because the idea is too abstract
and it's too far from the things that i
think about
or it's like a mathematical equation i'm
simply stuck on how to make the next
step
and in each of those cases examples
really help i mean with the
with the calculation oftentimes if i'm
trying to do an abstract calculation i
try to do 10
examples of the calculation first not
try to prove the theorem
which is universal i just look at
example after example after example
and i try to see a pattern in
the calculations and with that pattern i
then go to the abstract one that stumped
me
and i say oh wait a second from those
four examples
now i believe i understand the right
move to make here
and i try to make that move in
determining the next step that might get
me
unstuck and similarly for purely
abstract ideas oftentimes what i'll do
is
i'll say this is really abstract i don't
quite get it let me see if i can find an
example of this abstract idea
and then i find another example and i'm
like okay now
it's coming into focus now i understand
what i'm doing
because rather than focus solely on the
abstract i've got these concrete
examples that i that i can study so
that's probably
the best way that i can summarize my own
process
when i got stuck on things um
a few more questions i'm gonna have to
go actually because i just saw a truck
roll up here because um
we're actually building a small little
space near here where i'll be able to do
these live sessions
a little bit more easily than the manner
that we're doing them here and
and film various programs that we'd like
to release
on the world science festival website so
the construction workers are here
yay they're going to break ground today
that's exciting
um james mitchell what's my favorite
music well that's off the beaten track
but why not my favorite music oh
well uh classical music i'd say
i find the most moving brahms
is my probably my favorite composer you
know beethoven not anything weird or
unexpected
but you know there's some popular music
show
music film music that i think is
wonderful too
so i'm kind of all over the place but
with the big focus
on you know brahms symphony 3
beethoven symphony 9 brahms
piano concerto rhapsody and g minor
those are kind of the things that oh you
know what there's actually a program i
did um
on uh on i guess it must have been bbc
radio
where uh it was all about your favorite
music so if you search under that i
can't remember the exact name of the
show but it's a nice
it was a nice uh survey of
well of different individuals the music
that they find um
most meaningful so there's a whole
60-minute program that you can find if
that really interests you um
okay what else have we got here in the
last few minutes
um
um let's see uh
let me see if i can find uh so muhammad
swali what is our latest understanding
about singularities
and that's a big open-ended question
singularities come in different flavors
what is a singularity it's a
it's a situation when we're doing a
calculation
when the calculation breaks down how
does it break down
we get something like one divided by
zero we're like oh my god what does that
infinite expression mean or
you know something where um
there's just an undefined mathematical
term that pops
into uh our calculations
the one divided by zero is probably the
best example of all that sort of thing
happens
and when we find those in our physics
calculations we usually interpret it as
meaning that our physical theories have
broken down
there aren't any one divided by zero
calculations that are actually
relevant to the real world the real
world doesn't have
those kinds of infinities crop up so
generally we try to modify our physical
theories
so that singularities don't emerge
don't arise and we've been successful
we've been successful certainly so there
are certain kinds of singularities that
we have found the math to cure
the flop transition that was mentioned
uh earlier like an hour and a half ago
that was an example where sphere
collapses down to zero size and that
zero size
is the zero volume and when you talk
about density
mass divided by volume a zero volume is
a bad thing it's got
divided by zero in the bottom so
mathematically you understand how that
could
arise but physically you're like no no
that can't describe the real world
and indeed string theory cured that
particular
singularity the singularity that would
come from a flop
transition there are other singularities
though that we've yet
to resolve and we hope that one day we
will we believe that quantum mechanics
sort of
fuzzes out little tiny sizes so if you
do have a
a puncture divided by zero volume that
quantum mechanics will kind of fuzz that
out into something non-zero
so that that's the general way in which
we envision quantum effects
curing singularities but as yet we do
not have a
universal answer where we can say all
singularities are now
cured here's the solution that's not
the way it works that's not the way
that things have transpired at least not
yet
um rachet asked is string theory
why we could feel emotions due to music
and vibrations around
i don't think so i mean i get the the
the the reasoning there you know if
strings if we're made of strings and
strings have resonant vibrations and
then there's actual vibrations in the
outer world
could there be some kind of sympathetic
resonance between
the vibrations of music and the
vibrations of strings that make us
up and that inspires emotion and the
answer to that is no
as far as i can tell the scales are just
radically different
so when i talk about the strings of
string theory i'm talking about
something that's probably
you know 10 to the minus 30 10 to the
minus 35 meters across
the physical processes that give rise to
emotion rely upon the physics down there
but take place
on scales that are orders and orders of
magnitude larger
so who knows maybe one day we'll
understand brain processes well enough
to line up emotion with physics
i think we can in principle do that one
day
but do i anticipate that that alignment
of emotion
and physics will be as crude
as you know vibrations of strings and
vibrations of music no
i don't think i mean cruz the wrong word
i don't mean to say it that way
will it be as direct that's a better way
of saying no i do not think it will be
it'll be much much more indirect because
the scales
have to bubble up from 10 to minus 35
meters to 10 to the minus 30 to 10 to
the minus
20 then to minus 10 till finally it gets
up to
the kinds of physiochemical
physiobiological processes that happen
inside the brain
at a direct manner yielding
inner experience of course if strings
are strings and they're in the brain
then
those processes are happening but i
don't
think there'll be a direct link between
that string vibrating
and you feeling excited when that high g
happened in the aria and the puccini
you know it's just i i i don't think
that kind of a direct link will ever
ever be found all right let's go on for
another couple minutes
sort of sometimes like the cross a three
hour limit
just uh just to prove to myself that i
can do it
[Music]
do your thoughts have vibrations angel
uv
s dmv asks uh yeah sort of i mean
thoughts
are the product of brain processes
brain processes ultimately emerge from
the processes
of the particles making up the brain and
quantum mechanically the particles
making up the brain
do have quantum mechanical vibrations
there's a schrodinger equation that
describes the wave function of these
particles and that wave undulates
in a manner dictated by schrodinger's
equation
so in some in some abstract way
it is the case that you know thoughts
are vibrations but again as my friend
ken weinberg always asks me to emphasize
like ken weinberg actually designed the
building that this truck just came in to
start building so all
everything's coming together here this
is the finale of our session here and
it's all coming together
can always feels like i mislead people
if i don't in the next breath
emphasize that a chunk of swiss cheese
also has vibrations because the
particles that make
up it are governed by the schrodinger
equation of quantum mechanics
and that wave of schrodinger vibrates
inside the swiss cheese too
so it's not like thoughts inside the
brain in my description
are having a vibrational quality that is
somehow
different from the vibrational quality
of the particles inside the block of
swiss cheese
so so when we say that quantum mechanics
is relevant to the brain and
consciousness
we're thinking about it in a manner
that's not special to the brain that
applies equally well to
inanimate objects like a chunk of swiss
cheese
will we one day be able to say something
more refined
that really does link up
the experience of consciousness with
some direct
quantum mechanical quality of the world
that i don't know
for that we don't have any evidence we
don't have
any reason to believe it yet but we
don't have any reason not to believe it
either
so remains to be
seen all right we got a minute and 50
seconds left
oh oh wait a second we have the visual
what a way to end
this is a visual extra dimension so look
at this guys that is space on large
scales you don't see anything but the
dimensions on the screen but
according to these ideas if you go small
enough
you can have extra curled up dimensions
look at them these little curled up tiny
circles that you miss and if you have a
little microscopic ant walking around
the ant would have access to these extra
dimensions even though we big
lumbering beings would be unaware of
their existence
and again an idea like string theory
doesn't say that the extra dimensions
are curled up into little circles per se
string theory actually
suggests that the extra dimensions are
curled up into more exotic shapes
these little so-called columbial shapes
named after two mathematicians
kalabi and yao and yao was also one of
my supervisors
it turns out and so these ideas are
correct
this is a shape
that might constitute the extra curled
up dimensions of string theory so as you
pull back
the big dimensions that we experience
that's the grid
you can only show two on a flat screen
and the extra curled up dimensions these
beautiful shapes
these beautiful kalabi yao shapes so
when i was talking about these flop
transitions i was actually talking about
flop transitions
inside those curled up purple shapes you
take a clavial shape for the extra
dimensions
you squeeze down a sphere inside of it
it punctures that shape
you then flop it over and inflate it in
a different
direction and that repairs the
singularity
in a physically smooth manner but
changes the topology
the fundamental shape of that clavial
shape so there we go
wow i think we have to give a little
round of applause
for the world science festival team for
grabbing hold of that
visual in real time and i think that's a
pretty
good place for us to end that intuitive
explanation for the
extra dimensions of space that comes out
of the mathematics of string theory but
again
until these ideas are observationally
confirmed or experimentally confirmed
they're just speculative ideas but let
me now
to end reflect back on the first hour of
our session
the idea of gravitational waves was just
as speculative as the idea of
extra dimensions when the idea of
gravitational waves first
emerged mathematically in 1916 in a
paper of albert einstein
and yet today we had a conversation
with a member of the ligo team here in
the 21st century recounting
that on september 14th of 2015
the idea speculative though it may be of
gravitational waves was confirmed
through an observation
was not an easy experiment wasn't an
easy observation
but that pattern from abstract
mathematical idea
to confirmed observation is the kind
of rhythm that inspires
us theorists that keeps us theorists
going that keeps us
theorists imagining that one day we too
might have an experiment or an
observation that confirms ideas of extra
dimensions
confirmed ideas of string theory maybe
one of you
the young members of the internet
audience now listening to this maybe you
way
you will be inspired one day to build
the device that shows us the
reality of extra dimensions the reality
of strength how
how exciting would that be but again as
i mentioned
in my advice to young aspiring
physicists
be inspired by that possibility be
inspired by the possibility of
discovering a quality of the world that
we've thought about for a long time but
nobody
has yet detected be inspired by that
possibility but
spend your time learning
the basics inside out it's the only
road to success learn the basics inside
out
all right so thank you all for um for
sticking with us for this
three hour session i think we'll be back
probably not
next tuesday but maybe the tuesday after
but i'm not going to commit to a time
because the times are bouncing around a
little bit
but you know subscribe there's some sign
of subscribe button somewhere
that you can see please join us as part
of the world science
festival and world science you community
and uh i look forward
to having this ongoing dialogue this
ongoing conversation
and the uh continue in the not too
distant future until then
stay safe and
looking forward to seeing you then
you